there's just way too much news
way too much news welcome back everybody
I hope you had an amazing holiday we are
off for Thanksgiving and Black Friday
and uh I wake up on this Monday just
looking at all of the stories and it's
overwhelming
um we had we were struggling to figure
out like what do we lead with we got
Jesse Smollett he's going to trial the
ocean dyro brothers who claim uh who are
who allegedly were hired by him to stage
this hoax are gonna be testifying
against him at least that's what I've
been hearing we've got Jack Dorsey the
CEO of Twitter stepping down we've got
Joe Biden saying we don't need to do any
lockdowns for now so long as you get
vaccinated and now reports are coming
out saying oops it's actually a three
dose vaccine not a booster so what does
that mean well the definitions are going
to change we got Anthony fauci coming
out once again for I think I don't know
how many times that I am the science
then getting slammed by politicians and
we decided to start off with Chris Cuomo
because this is a big media story Cuomo
Chris Cuomo and CNN was covering for his
brother amid assault alligator we'll
keep it a little family friendly and he
was apparently stalking the victims and
trying to dig up dirt on them and even
crafted the pr statement for his brother
we'll get into all that reporting he may
get fired I really doubt it Brian
Williams can literally make up stories
and they're like just move into MSNBC
where no one cares about what's true or
not Jeffrey two wins
CNN hired that guy back
who could have I mean the remarkable
thing is there was there a video of
tubing I think so wow so we got to get
into all of that stuff but we are
hanging out with uh white coat waste
project I got that right right yeah you
did Justin you want to introduce
yourself sure I'm uh Justin Goodman I'm
the vice president of advocacy and
public policy at white coat waste
project
I spend my days protecting dogs and
puppies and kittens and monkeys from
government abuse like Dr fauci
protecting them from evil the evil guys
like that yeah so we actually have a
storytimecast.com uh by of which I get
you guys were the source a source for it
that fauci is conducting maximum pain
experiments on primates on Monkey Island
and this is I had to so this this is I
don't like doing this I had to go into
the article and actually take the
pictures off because they're so gruesome
we can't show them on YouTube
and this is the you know niaid under
fauci funding pain research you have to
wonder about some of the cruel and
psychotic things they do in the name of
research on animals some of which is
just nonsensical like do fish feel pain
or let's torture monkeys as much as
possible see what happens I'm sorry man
I I kind of I'm I'm interested what you
have to say about waste project because
this sounds like cruel unusual and a
waste of our money yeah absolutely it
costs taxpayers 20 billion dollars a
year billion with a B I mean we can just
look at all these lefties and be like
hey how about we all agree and we like I
don't know fund roads or something or or
put it towards some kind of healthcare
project I think it's better than
torturing animals and stuff like that or
just don't don't steal the money in the
first place and let people keep their
income I think that's a great idea lots
of news to get into today including the
lane Maxwell trial which just began with
of course James comey's daughter who's
one of the lead prosecutors and the same
person who admittedly lost the Epstein
prison tapes looks like she got a
promotion we're going to be talking
about that probably in the after section
but I think today's shirt that I'm
wearing definitely is appropriate for
our conversation it says fauci lied
people died and I think I might have to
add another uh audible to the shirt
saying people monkeys dogs and a whole
bunch of other people and and creatures
that we don't even know about uh with
5g's eye so I'm excited to get into that
plus a lot more and if you want the
shirt you can on the best
politicalshirts.com and because you do
that I'm here thanks for having me happy
to be back Ian Crossland over here happy
holidays everyone and uh looking forward
to the show let's get going good yeah I
am also here pushing buttons in the
corner as is my want I'm very excited to
have white Coast Waste project if I can
like it's a tongue but yeah no don't
confuse me further thank you that's why
I was like slow I was like white I just
use white coat white coat white coat
perfect yeah and yeah I'm here yes all
right sorry before we get started ladies
and gentlemen we got an awesome sponsor
this I'm really excited about go to
backupsolarbank.com use promo code cyber
monday for a massive discount they say
on the website you get a whopping 47 off
your solar backup charger you can plug
your phone into it and also if you use a
promo code cyber monday you get another
25 off this is actually really cool so
what I'm holding here for those that can
see it is it's a battery pack I think
everybody should have a battery pack for
your phone
um when I was doing live streaming on
the ground I had like four or five of
these but they were basic wall Chargers
and they didn't have lights on them they
didn't have three different charger
ports and they weren't able to charge
through solar so right now as I'm
holding this up there's little lights
you can see this thing is actually
charging up from the room lights this is
amazing and it is what it is it's 20 000
milliamps that basically means like 10
full phone charges and it's also got
wireless charging so I'm actually really
excited to have them on as a sponsor
again go to backupsolarbank.com 47 off
and using the promo code cyber monday
you get another 25 off and we've got
some important information for you if my
phone works
for uh it's a high capacity battery 20
000 milliamps backup power portable and
essential and emergency it's got
wireless charging it will recognize your
phone instantly for wireless charging if
you have it compatible with most phones
and electronic devices charge anytime
anywhere it also has an SOS strobe light
feature that can be seen for miles and
also it's a flashlight it's easy to use
to get the job done capable of handing
any weather condition ipx4 Splash proof
and shock proof small enough to carry
two to three times faster than ordinary
solar charges Chargers bi-directional
fast charging best solar Bank on the
market oh that's interesting and charges
three devices simultaneously I actually
uh we we needed one of these recently
and I'm really glad that they sent us
this um because I I needed it and I'm
really excited so this is really cool
plus we've been doing these trips we're
planning on going about once a month off
in the RV and we're getting a big solar
build out done on the RV we're getting
so having this as an additional backup
for when you go off the grid is going to
be absolutely incredible go to
backupsolarbank.com promo code cyber
monday and don't forget to go to
timcast.com become a member help support
all of our journalists we have a new
show launching I think tomorrow because
we're just going to go for it it's a pop
culture show talking about movies video
games and all that stuff we'll get a
little bit into politics for the most
part it's going to be just like cultural
because we want to build that culture
but you're also supporting all of our
journalists of note Cassandra Fairbanks
who wrote about fauci's monkey torture
Island and we also which info with
information sourced from white coat
which is going to be an excellent
conversation today so certainly help
support all of our work you can also
support our work by going to the timcast
store from the website and getting a
shirt like this one step on snack and
find out YouTube didn't approve it for
us to display on YouTube I guess they
don't like it but I really like it and I
think it's a silly joke and it's funny
and if you like it with a cute little
snake and he's a little angry you know
he's a tough guy then uh get that get
that shirt don't forget to like this
video smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends let's get in to that big story
oh man
Daily Mail reports CNN says Chris
Cuomo's fate will be decided in the next
several days after text messages
revealed he wrote Andrew's pest
rebuttals assault Pest rebuttals and
used sources to dig dirt on accuser the
victim says system protects powerful men
from accountability newly released tax
joho CNN host Chris Cuomo helped
strategize his brother's response to
harassment allegations CNN told
dailymail.com transcripts of Cuomo's
interview with investigators in the
texts will be reviewed we'll be having a
conversation and seeking additional
clarity about their significance as they
relate to CNN over the next several days
so maybe he won't be fired but we'll see
a March 1st message he sent to the
governor's chief aide Melissa DeRosa
included included a suggested written
response Andrew Cuomo should have used
the messages were released by the New
York attorney general's office Monday
in one Chris said his friend asked actor
Alec Baldwin to post a 14-minute video
rant on Instagram in defense of his
disgraced Governor brother grassetti
asked his friend to to tell Baldwin to
stay out of the Scandal the texts also
reveal the television personality was
investigating one woman who accused the
exploitation of trying to kiss her at a
wedding
DeRosa and Cuomo would often send her
unsolicited advice which she often
ignored
all right Cuomo he's not a journalist he
is a content creator for CNN and I'm
gonna make sure I give proper credit
where credit is due this is Danny and
Ryan long Danny uh polish Chuck I'm
probably pronouncing your name wrong
Danny but they had this funny event on
their podcast about how you know it
would just really irk the media by
calling all their journalists content
creators and Ryan long is like the right
would roll with it and be like I guess
whatever and the left would just freak
out no we're journalists no no hold on
Chris Cuomo's not doing journalism here
he's directly intervening in a political
Scandal using a media Network to protect
his corrupt brother who assaulted women
who had killed the elderly and all of
this CNN helped cover up not a
journalist but he does make content so I
think it's fair to call Como content
creator and he was lying about it from
the very beginning of this Scandal CNN
said that they were investigating ties
between the brother the governor and of
course the anchor and they're looking
into it and they're going to have a
thorough investigation and now we have
the New York State
attorney general released all these text
messages that implicate him I mean I'm
really surprised that CNN is not going
to give him a medal in Excellency of of
lying and deception I mean CNN for
Frick's sakes look at their lineup they
got Lubin tubing they got they got they
had the brain eating guy they got a
Vanderbilt they got they got the guy who
talks about black holes swallowing
airplanes and now they have creepy Como
I mean CNN is not a news organization
they are a smear Merchant operation that
does the bidding and the pr of the super
powerful that wants to impose their will
or their Willy onto the unsuspecting
innocent public and I am sick of these
people having carte blanche promotion by
all these big Tech social media
companies sorry I had that lined up I'm
so mad at CNN the brain eating guy yeah
that's their lineup I mean
that's the most trusted he's not but
that's the most trusted name in news
they had people eating brains on
National Television promoting that scene
YouTube's like that's great that's
awesome that's family friendly content
that we got to push in the algorithm
meanwhile Independent Media like my
channel your channel we are changed we
get screwed over and of course we get
down ranked and you know there's so many
instances CNN even I I'm a little biased
here obviously CNN put a false strike on
one of my videos and prevented me from
doing live streams when I had a live
show because I played a portion of the
president's speech which was during the
State of the Union so they they rigged
the algorithm in many different ways but
regardless Chris Como should be
obviously fired here but with the low
reputation that CNN has will he that's
the larger question that I think a lot
of people are asking them how long did
it take you to write all that look that
was during the show you're doing the
introduction
you're doing the introduction I'm like I
could go on a roll here the brain eating
guy yeah
oh man wow CNN's reputation could not be
worse you know I I had an idea I woke up
the other morning uh no I think it was
it this morning maybe
um I usually wake up and then I just
like I don't know man I'm coming off a
groggy weird dream and I'm like vaguely
remembering what's going on I I
immediately pick up my phone right when
I wake up and I hit up Twitter and then
the first thing I saw was a tweet from
Brian stelter about the Omicron variant
and then I was just like stelter variant
and I was like oh wait a minute this is
a good idea I was like we should just
call the name the variants after CNN's
lineup yeah and so I was like I'm not
gonna call it I'm gonna call it the
lemon variant because lemon's actually
like a regular word too and so we'll
just name all the variants ever CNN
hosts yeah and I call them content
creators too because I agree like
they're not journalists they just make
content and truth be told this is really
important
seriously we talk about CNN's ratings
being complete trash and in the gutter
and that's true but they do get a ton of
YouTube video uh views because YouTube
promotes them so CNN's lineup they get I
think they get like 100 to 200k in the
key demo and like all all together it's
only like 400 so they're well below the
ratings of this show and I'm not saying
that to like braggers I'm just pointing
out like they're irrelevant but they get
the YouTube views more than we do and
we're on YouTube so they're just content
creators that's all they are but a lot
of that is forced a lot of that is the
algorithm literally pushing them no
matter who's online usually the
algorithm is curated for a particular
audience but you look up any kind of
news related event CNN is top up up
there so they have a huge advantage over
of course Independent Media when they're
causing real life harm uh you know CNN
and other corporate media make the
argument that Independent Media is
causing arm to the general public by
lying and spreading misinformation well
number one look at exactly what CNN did
whether it's the Hurricane Katrina the
2008 bailouts whether it's the weapons
of mass destruction time and time again
they kept lying through their teeth that
led to real life consequences even on a
smaller micro level when we look at
Chris Cuomo literally going after
looking up dirts using CNN's resources
to go after the accusers of his brother
who's governor of New York who's been
accused of doing really inappropriate
stuff to other female members of his
staff family friendly show we can't get
really into the details here a lot of it
is also vague but that that should be
the least thing that Como should be in
trouble for we can we can a lot of the
allegations are like when he grabbed
that woman by the neck and like Paul
Duran and she's like clearly freaked out
then Cuomo himself put out a montage of
him inappropriately touching people to
justify be okay it was funny because he
was like I'm I'm an Italian you know I
touch everybody here's a video of me
doing it and you're just like oh it's
making it worse yeah it's like all these
videos of him like grabbing faces of
random people and I'm like it doesn't
make you innocent it make just makes you
a bisexual assailant but it wasn't just
faces it wasn't just people feeling
uncomfortable it was also people being
touched in other private areas it was
also forcefully kissing them and making
them feel really uncomfortable by making
a lot of innuendos and kind of Demands
and of course you know that thing is
still nothing compared to what he did to
the state of New York during of course
the beginning of covid with his policy
when it came to Elderly Homes and the
larger impact that he had on the large
number of people that died as a
consequence because of his direct
policies that killed people so that to
me should be the bigger controversy it
shouldn't be of course uh you know a lot
of the pr stuff it shouldn't be a lot of
the lighter stuff because there is some
lighter stuff mixed in with some of the
heavier stuff but this shows a kind of
um you know you know characterization of
someone who's Above the Law who who
thinks that they could do whatever they
want who routinely abuses people around
them and they think they could get away
with it because they're in a high
position of power that's the kind of
kind of Grease ball thinking that should
be called out because it leads to of
course on a lower level people feeling
uncomfortable on a bigger level Grandma
being pushed in with the latest covid
cases inside of her nursing home because
he thinks he could get away with it and
he has Andrew Cuomo killed like 15 000
people easily that's the numbers we know
he hid the numbers he lied about the
numbers so those numbers are probably a
lot bigger and the fact that he made
that policy the fact that he hid that
policy is also another big aspect here
because he was caught lying manipulating
the data manipulating the information
the new governor of New York came out
and said hey there's actually a lot more
people here that were caught up in this
there's actually a lot more people here
that were affected by this that we
didn't even know about and I mean when
you get to this kind of level of social
osteopathic thinking this kind of level
of making these decisions that that
impact people so negatively this is
absolutely nothing but it still should
be called out for they still should be
held accountable for all the egregious
actions that they're doing it's because
they hated Trump so much yes it was that
Trump sent in the mercy a naval vessel
and the Javits Center had been opened
for emergency uh usage and the mercy I
don't believe was ever used maybe like
one or two beds something the Javits was
at 30 but Cuomo was like let's not give
Trump a win and so he put recovering
coveted patients were still infectious
into nursing homes and uh in in
Pennsylvania where this was happening
too under Governor Tom Wolf it was the
now
um Admiral yeah honorary Admiral of uh
whatever Biden's appointee for Health
Services Rachel Rachel Levine right yeah
yeah took their parents out of a nursing
home just before the sick people were
put in yeah that shows uh for knowledge
yeah they were were going to be killing
the elderly they didn't care they knew
they had hospitals that were wide open
in the middle of Central Park that were
just put there there were field
hospitals and there was no one in them
so why would you do this kind of policy
it absolutely makes no sense at all and
the fact that he didn't go down for that
the fact that he went down for something
else later down the line shows you that
there's bigger things at hand here
there's more political manipulation here
there's a there's a bigger power
structure that probably did ensue
between the comos and another Power
structure there's probably a bigger ask
by the power structure that Como
probably didn't want to go along with
but also with this latest Revelation
this is another another aspect to talk
about here because this was the New York
attorney general that released these
text messages and for people to think
that this is not political that this is
not done in a bigger power grab is also
I would say a little bit naive since of
course most New York politics is
extremely political extremely related to
criminal organizations criminal gangs as
well so I do believe that there's a
bigger power struggle here and they're
going after the Como is bringing them
down because of something else that we
might not even know about personally
from my own opinion let's wrap this back
to the the media aspect of it all
because when you know CNN lies in the
mainstream press lie over and over again
one of the outlets that we have is
social media however as most everybody
knows one of the biggest stories of Our
Generation the hunter Biden laptop
Scandal was censored by Twitter they
literally and Facebook they literally
blocked sharing of this link even in
private messages
likely just to help Joe Biden win the
election polling from Rasmussen and a
couple other outlets came out showing
that people I think by like seven point
percentage points would have not voted
for Joe Biden had they known about the
laptop Scandal and the things that Joe
Biden had been doing
and uh well with that being said we have
the story here most of you may have
heard this is one of the biggest stories
in a long time Jack Dorsey is resigning
as Twitter CEO board member and former
Chief technology officer parag agrawal
has been appointed CEO effective
immediately
You Know Jack Dorsey is a hypocrite he's
either well he's a hypocrite he's a liar
I believe or he's just completely inept
so
when I when I was talking to Jack and
I've talked to him several times since I
I met him on the Joe Rogan podcast
he was talking about a path to
Redemption for those that get banned you
can't make you know a life sentence
because you said a naughty word or
whatever he talked about solving the
problem and bringing about
decentralization and what did he do
after all these years literally nothing
but quit and appoint someone who is as
woke or woker than he is
this new guy the chief technology
officer parag agrawal he's got this
interview where I mean it's gone viral
he basically says uh let me see if I can
pull it up they ask him about it and let
me uh let me make sure I can pull up the
part where he talks about the First
Amendment
he's asked about free speech on Twitter
so we can expect things to get a whole
lot worse he says you're caught in a bit
of a hard place this is the interviewer
Litchfield as somebody in the audience
is also pointing out that you're trying
to combat misinformation you also want
to protect free speech is a core value
and also in the U.S as the first
amendment how do we balance those two he
said our role is not to be bound by the
First Amendment but our role is to serve
a healthy public conversation and our
moves are are reflective of things that
we believe lead to a healthier public
conversation the kinds of things that we
do about this is focused Less on
thinking about Free Speech but thinking
about how the times have changed one of
the changes today that we see is speech
is easy on the internet most people can
speak where our role is particularly
emphasized is who can be heard the
scarce commodity today is attention
there's lots of content out there a lot
of tweets out there not all of it gets
attention some subset of it gets
attention and so increasingly our role
is moving towards how we recommend
content and that sort of is a struggle
that we're working through in terms of
how we make sure these recommendation
systems that we're building thing how we
direct people's attention in leading to
a healthy public conversation that is
most participatory uh code word for we
know what's better for you than you do
and we're going to make sure that
conversations we deem to be the healthy
ones are had and promoted and your ideas
aren't and let's be real they directly
remove news stories that are bad for
their psychotic goals and agendas and I
want to give a shout out real quick to
project Veritas who has those Undercover
videos of Bernie Sanders supporters and
Democrat staffers talking about being
violent and manipulating people and
talking about gulags because if you ever
talk to these anti-food people in
private they will straight up tell you
they intend to kill millions of people
and I'm not I'm not exaggerating I'm not
trying to push hyperbole I mean
literally go to these meetings and they
will calmly these anti-fafar leftists
calmly and rationally say things like
you know if we want communism we have to
reconcile with the fact there's going to
be you know tens of millions of people
who will actively resist many of whom
will violently resist to uphold
capitalism white supremacy insert
buzzword and they'll say well those
people have to be sent to the gulags to
break rocks to understand what hard work
really means many of whom will die
when you see stories like this and
you've got psychotic ego maniacal
lunatics like this guy agrawal and Jack
Dorsey saying we know what's healthy not
you you don't get to speak
what do you think what do you think the
future will look like under that kind of
person well we were already in that spot
with with CEO Jack Dorsey but I gotta Be
Honest Jack Dorsey didn't do a whole lot
and he still was willing to go on shows
and talk to people this guy I think is
going to be much more locked down much
more robotic PR oriented just garbage
statements put out lies manipulation and
as much as I think Twitter is trash it
does still have that opportunity to
spread news outside the mainstream
whereas CNN is is a pollutant I know you
know with with uh you guys at white coat
getting these stories out probably is
difficult because I don't think CNN
would go near anything that smears
fouchy no it's been hard to get
mainstream media coverage for anything
criticizing fauci particularly in this
Administration uh we've taken them on
before under Trump a lot of these uh
news outlets were happy to cover us
beating up the administration and now
they're not anymore uh Twitter is
actively Banning ads right now from us
wow criticizing fauci we're trying to
run our dogs against fauchy ads about
him funding uh deadly maximum pain
experiments on dogs and Twitter dogs too
yeah Twitter banned Those ads they won't
give us a blue check either
um so we were hoping things would get
better when Jack left but it doesn't
sound like it I I don't think Jack was
that was really the CEO at this point
anyway I think they panicked I think who
was the CEO before him was it dick
costolo I don't know I don't remember
but uh I think they had a crisis they
were like bring Jack Dorsey back on
because he was a co-founder and it'll
look really really good you know to our
investors or whatever and then Jack just
basically made a bunch of boring
nonsensical ideological public
statements and never actually
implemented anything yeah I mean this is
going to be a very interesting uh
transition of power I believe because I
think there's going to be some kind of
difference that we're going to be
feeling with this uh kind of um
transition this new guy coming in he
also has ties to of course Snopes and
politifacts so it's going to be
interesting to see how he implements
this a lot of people are bringing up his
old tweet from 2010 where he talked
about if you're gonna talk about Muslims
being all extremists then you should you
shouldn't distinguish between white
people and racists of course there's a
lot of different contexts behind that it
was a long time it was a quote from The
Daily Show yeah it was from Asif manvi
yeah but but honestly you know I never
thought I would say this and I'm
actually going to defend Jack Dorsey
here a little bit if you compare now
what Twitter is to Facebook and
Instagram it is way better especially
when it comes to censorship of speech
now that doesn't say much that's like
comparing like uh uh you know the devil
to to you know a different smaller devil
but you know like Lucifer I was gonna
say it's still the devil it's still evil
but uh I've personally noticed having a
lot more fun and a lot more freedom on
Twitter than I would on Instagram and
Facebook because I've been getting fact
checked a lot more on Facebook and
Instagram than I have on Twitter and
there's a lot of stuff I get away with
on Twitter that I would naturally not
get away with now of course I could be
mixed in in the crowd I could not be
targeted a lot of people have been
targeted a lot of people have had their
speech uh aggressively limited which is
absolutely horrible Timmy got something
to say well it's it's not that Twitter's
better it's that they're all different
Facebook is the Worst by far because
they ban everything they put fake fact
checks on things they Empower political
actors to lie about statements you know
if I've made or you make YouTube is
actually decent in some areas but really
really bad in terms of General
censorship Twitter is good in some areas
but really really bad in terms of
censorship sure you know Twitter allows
you to talk about a lot of things like
fauci and the vaccines if you're just
tweeting but what you don't know is when
they Shadow ban you and then you got to
do a check or they won't verify certain
people they won't verify uh you know
actually I think they banned James
O'Keefe completely yeah so yeah they
wouldn't verify him there's a lot of
people they won't verify and that
verification is a sign of credibility
and they know it and Trust now YouTube
allows you to say some things but
YouTube is worse than Twitter so I think
it's it's fair to point out they're all
bad but if like I was going to give a
censorship score where a positive score
means your pro free speech and a
negative score means you oppose Free
Speech then you know Facebook is like a
negative 93 and YouTube is a negative 65
and then Twitter is a negative you know
47. they're all opposed to free speech
like a 43 a 50 maybe but I'm along the
same lines but it's still one of the
still one of the places where you could
share a lot of controversial ideas
without having the band hammer Instagram
I know oh I'm gonna post this I'm gonna
get banned I'm gonna get hit right away
I I just know so so there's also
something interesting happening with
Jack Dorsey tweeting a lot of very
curious stuff he tweeted out Murray's
rothbard's book an anatomy of the State
uh recently as well he's really into
Bitcoin so I don't know maybe he got
surprised dosed and had some kind of
Revelation there's also rumors of him
having a shake up an argument with
Elliot management that's the hedge fund
that's pretty much uh has a substantial
stake in Twitter so I wouldn't be
surprised if there were some bigger
moves here made uh Jack Dorsey also just
previously said a couple months ago if
he wasn't working at Twitter he would be
working in Bitcoin so uh just the fact
that he has promoted Bitcoin as much as
he can that he even tweeted out Murray's
rothbard's book is is pretty huge so
there might be some kind of Awakening up
or some kind of internal conflict that
we don't even know about that has caused
this larger shake-up which I do believe
there's going to be some ramifications
of maybe maybe uh you know I don't want
to take the just the direct pessimistic
view of this guy as a do-nothing
hypocrite maybe the reality is there is
a lot of stuff that Jack Dorsey talked
about doing with Bitcoin with crypto
with decentralization and maybe he just
couldn't do it maybe they wouldn't let
him do it maybe they said it's bad for
our bottom line so no and he eventually
said okay I'm gonna leave and go do it
yeah so maybe he'll work in blockchain
technology he told me this years ago he
said that you know we need decentralized
blockchain social media that's immutable
and I said that's a really bad idea
because that means someone could post my
address and it could never be deleted
and I would not be happy with you know
that private information or you know
personal images or something like that
there needs to be a way to remove that
stuff and he was like okay well I see
your point but decentralized social
media way better and I said that we
agree on but in all these years he's
never gotten any of that done so maybe
he's just completely ineffective and it
was a waste of time for him to even
bother at Twitter maybe we shouldn't
give the man the benefit of the doubt
because he's never proven anything he's
done has was in in the right direction
in terms of helping people on the social
media platform I thought Square was
pretty cool I don't know too much about
it that other company that he started in
2009 he basically left Twitter in 2010
resigned his CEO started Square which is
like a financial app and then uh they
brought him back for the face game to
look nice I would love to interview him
if we could get him to sit down and talk
about I mean he probably won't be able
to even talk about their inner drama
that happened with a lot of the bigger
players behind Twitter because Twitter
has a lot of big players Twitter also
has a lot of Saudi Arabian investment so
there's there's a lot of you know things
happening behind the doors that we don't
even know about that I wish I could be a
fly on the wall when they're discussing
a lot of these issues but we'll see what
he does after this this I mean I think
he's going to be going into the Bitcoin
realm I think it's very easy to say that
he said that before so it's going to be
interesting to see where he goes from
here and I mean I would just love to
talk to him to be honest with you I'm
gonna DM him right now that'd be awesome
be like hey do you want to come and have
a conversation about
um what's going on here we want to give
you a fair play to address yourself and
and talk about your larger projects I
think I would love to question him on a
lot of different stuff but uh we'll see
what he's able to say and what he's not
able to say I think all this stuff from
this news CT CEO the former CTO I think
um it really smacks at this rank elitism
because talking about how we know what's
best for you just it looks exactly like
it's currently the science Community
talking about we know what's best for
you and even when people are actively
being hurt by some of these things that
they're pushing through they're like we
still know what's best for you you have
no say in your life you don't know
what's right and Thomas Soul talks about
this too he talks about how we're
entrusting a lot of society to people
who pay no price for being wrong
somebody pointed out on Twitter earlier
today they were like um it's really
interesting that we lock down that
millions of people are like out of work
that people are committing suicide Left
Right and center and the only people who
are paying no price for this are the
people who put it into place like that
doesn't seem right but this is just just
disgusting elitism I think it's someone
come for the First Amendment someone
commented on my Facebook because I said
something I don't know is it about it it
was probably about like lockdowns or
Australia and they were just like I
wonder what occupy Tim would be saying
about Tim today day he'd probably be
he'd probably be saying things like oh
you got really into guns everything else
seems to be all right like Freedom
Liberty free speech like when I was not
at occupied defending people's right to
free speech I'm like it's for the same
reason I don't agree with their politics
but like by all means do your protests
complain about the elites but I bring
that up because of what you were saying
about the elites here we are as a show
that gets smeared or we get insulted we
get smeared they claim we're right wing
or whatever which whatever that means
and we're literally like the one percent
you know the elites are ripping us off
Steve Bannon comes on the show and he's
like you gotta tax the rich man and I
was like Steve that's a far left
position you know like it's not the
conservative or the right wing that
wants to do that and he's like well you
know the billionaires are ripping you
off and I'm like all right like I'm down
and I think the that's the thing about
the media that's why social media
decentralization is so important CNN is
going to lie to you MSNBC is going to
lie MSNBC boy do they lie I mean come on
Brian Williams my name is Brian Williams
right he made up that fake story about
being shot out yeah yeah and then
they're all like move them to MSNBC
because those people don't care if
they're lied to yeah yeah that's crazy
so we need to have a space where we can
actually challenge a system the funny
thing about this is you know like I
mentioned here we are challenging and
questioning the elites and the
establishment Steve Bannon did the same
thing and there were people watching the
show being like whoa I didn't know that
was bannon's position because the media
had lied so much about him saying he was
like a white supremacist and a racist
and all that stuff when in reality he's
just a general populist he's not even he
calls himself far right but I'm like
you're just a populist yeah like there's
left and right-wing positions in what
you're saying it's not even I'm like I
think one of the things is
if with the left if we I maybe we should
do this we should invite a leftist
populist to come on the show with Steve
Bannon so we can hear them say I agree
the entire show and just break the The
Narrative seriously Kyle Kolinski you
want to come on the show with Steve
Bannon would you think you think that'd
be cool yeah and then have them talk
about all the things they agree on and
be like oh wow we agree on so much stuff
that sounds interesting he was lying
about this I wonder if Kyle I mean you
know the thing about left populace is
they have their own shows to do for the
most part so it's always hard to be like
stop doing your show come do my show but
um I'm sure there are some left
populists who would be interested in in
coming on having a conversation yeah I
mean if it wasn't for big Tech social
media if it wasn't for the corporate
media we would figure out that we have a
lot more in common than we do that's
dividing us I think there is a larger
divide and conquer agenda I think
there's even things made up to divide us
whether it's sex and gender or beliefs
or ideologies I think a lot of it is
interjected in a way where it's divisive
and it's divisive on purpose so of
course we keep fighting each other
instead of real realizing the larger
bigger players out there who are
screwing everyone else over literally
committing one of the largest transfers
of wealth and recorded human history
which is ongoing right now because of
this pandemic which of course is
creating a new billionaire class that is
becoming richer than ever and everyone
else is getting screwed over I had uh
what was the guy's name who was a part
of the Trump Administration Peter
Navarro yeah he was on here he called me
a Bernie supporter I felt I felt so so
offended but he probably came from that
perspective after he heard a lot of my
critiques of the kind of ruling
establishment because a lot of people
correlate the two but you know it's
further from the truth but if I would
say on a political Spectrum I probably
have a lot of issues that a lot of B
Bernie supporters would probably agree
with me on if they were able to hear me
out if they were able to talk to me if
they were able to have a real honest
conversation
um and I think that's what a lot of
people are afraid of they're afraid of
people sitting down having that real
conversation being able to discuss their
differences in a way that's peaceful and
respectful because when you do that you
break down all the things that are of
course are screwing people over and
conning them into this Left Right divide
and conquer game I think
if we ask Steve Bannon like if like we
got him with Kyle Kolinski he'd probably
just be like yes right off the bat yeah
I think you probably think it was fun
but I think Kyle would probably be like
let me think about it yeah of course so
I'll just I don't know and I you know I
think it's maybe because you know Bannon
I think is wealthy enough to be like
sure we'll do it and Kyle's gotta you
know full-time jobs gotta do a show but
I also I I don't think Kyle is the kind
of person who would play you know stupid
games like a lot of a lot of you know
grifter Types on the left or the right
would do the right always wants to come
on for a debate no matter who they are
but a lot of people left are worried
about cancel culture and stuff I just
want to say this real quick before we go
to the next story Kyle Kolinski big fan
come on the show with Steve Bannon we'll
set it up and I think it'll be an
awesome conversation and we'll just
we'll we'll try it we'll talk through
all these issues about where we agree
where we disagree I think it'll be
fascinating right everybody agree
absolutely yeah absolutely yeah Kyle's
rad he had a tweet where he was like I
just want a Democrat that's not Ultra
woke and isn't gonna you know Bend like
bow down to the media and I'm like yes
yes of course and then someone said
isn't that just Democrat Trump and I'm
like look maybe you get if we had if we
had a Democrat who wasn't just falling
in line with Pelosi and the rest of the
party who actually was like Hey I'm kind
of more to the left than the Republicans
but we agree on what the truth is we
think the media is full of it the ultra
work stuff is crap I'd be like all right
you know here we're getting somewhere I
think Tulsi gabber was very much like
that and they called her right wing so
now all of a sudden people are tweeting
that Kyle Kolinski was turning into
Jimmy Dore what and I was like um then
look if if Dave Rubin was on the left
and eyes on the right and Jimmy Dore was
on the left nose on the right and Cal
Collins he's going that direction maybe
you need to start looking at your boot
for what the crap really is because it's
not other people if you're not smelling
it yeah and they keep attacking people
who realize that we have a lot more in
common who try to bridge the gaps a lot
of leftists who don't always believe in
the cult don't always drink the Kool-Aid
they're the ones that get attacked the
most viciously by their own side so
seeing that happen is is also very
frustrating because you see a lot of
people play up to the Mob and try to be
popular and try to play up to their
audience members or their comment
section and you should never do that
because a lot of it is gamed a lot of it
is manipulated a lot of it is played to
emotionally and mentally control you in
so many different ways let's talk about
the censorship though because
um this is this is a really hilarious
story from timcast.com YouTube sensors
popular music video mocking fauci as a
sad little man I wonder if YouTube's
gonna get mad about uh this one from for
us covering it but uh it's from
um uh five times August YouTube sends a
music video from popular singer
songwriter five times times August over
its criticism of Dr Anthony fauci no
joke that's all the video is sad little
man there's fingers pointing at him he
sings a song and they actually take it
down
now the video has been reinstated after
public outcry but is not eligible for
monetization because YouTube claims it
violates their policy on dangerous and
harmful acts I have a music video
that I put out called will of the people
in it it shows revolutionaries throwing
Molotov cocktails and it's animated much
like this is animated and there's police
fighting with riders and revolutionaries
and there's literally a scene in it
where the main character pulls his gun
and points at the camera and pulls the
trigger and then the screen splatters
red and that is monetized acceptable
because why I'm not criticizing Dr fauci
criticizing Dr fauci in a music video
and they actually demonetize you that to
me is fascinating they say the animated
animated music video for the song sad
little man does not mention covet in the
lyrics but takes aim at the
authoritarianism and hero worship
surrounding the niaid director he is
portrayed throughout the video as a
clown and at one point Burns in heck
maybe that's the issue they take with it
but they reinstated it because showing a
person going to hell I guess is a
figurative thing not a literal thing but
either way this is this is the
censorship
and it's and it's so it's so blatant to
anybody who pays attention if you're
watching CNN and you've got creepy Cuomo
and the brain eating guy you have no
idea what's going on if you're on
YouTube and you're seeing videos pop up
they are desperately trying to stop that
the dislike button they got rid of it
right the display you can click the
button but now you can't see how many
dislikes a video has you want to know
why that's really dumb
dislikes are a functional tool to help
people understand a video so there's a
meme it was hilarious
it was like YouTube gets rid of dislike
counter and then it said people who make
fan trailers that are that are
manipulated and fake but claim it's real
and it's all it's a bunch of people
cheering and celebrating yeah yeah
because you'll search for like this this
happened to me I was searching for the
Spider-Man no way home trailer and I see
all these videos popping up with
millions of views says no way home
official no way home official and you
can't see the dislike button on anymore
on YouTube so you click it and before
you'd see a huge dislike and you're like
okay it's fake right everyone's saying
no no no it's fake and that's how you
knew now it's just like
okay it seems real it seems real and
then halfway in there's Matt Murdoch and
I'm like and it's not real and I just
wasted a minute it's not the trailer for
the movie so this is it they want to get
rid of the dislike button because people
were going after Joe Biden and the
Democrats in the White House disliking
it and that shows people you're not
alone they want to go after videos like
this now you can't tell the difference
between sad little man which is mocking
fauci with massive upvotes and then a
statement from fauci with massive
downvotes because you can't see which
one people hate they don't want you to
be able to understand where the general
population is so this is something I
talked about at the event because I was
like you know I feel like having this
many people in one room at one time is
really encouraging for people because it
does show that you're not alone and the
mainstream media 100 wants you to
believe that you are off the reservation
that you're losing your mind and that
you are like they just want to be able
to Gaslight you basically so I think
this is an example of that because if
you are the only person who so people
started to say you know we're just going
to comment dislike and then people can
upvote that comment and then people will
be able to uh people are very creative
and I don't see this being the end of
the world as far as YouTube goes but it
is a huge problem because tons of people
use tons of tutorials and they want to
know the actual truth why people are
really fouchy worship yes that's that's
the important thing here it's that you
criticize fauci and the cult goes nuts
the first thing they did was they took
the video down how dare you question
vouching he's
there's a video going around of um Jim
Brewer and it's actually pretty funny
I'm not gonna pretend like it's the
funniest thing in the world but Jim
Brewer is a funny like you know
character kind of uh comedian and he was
making fun of people as parrots who just
walk around parroting what they hear and
like Dr fauci get your shot get your
Shot Two Shots two shots and I was
chuckling but they were like on Reddit
they were so angry they were like this
is a comedy this is so dumb and I'm like
man they really hate it when you say
fauci is stupid like they really lose it
or you know does horrible experiments on
Little Monkeys and little helpless
puppies but we're gonna get into that in
just a little bit but getting rid of the
dislike button I mean who does that
really help I mean it helps a lot of
scammers it helps a lot of con artists
even if you're going to how-to videos
right how do you know if something
really is going to teach you how to do
something rather than of course scam you
waste your time or do a thing improperly
well you can anymore so I I remember
seeing that and saying this only helps
out scammers and I'm like yes exactly it
helps out the White House and Dr veggie
the biggest scammers of all who of
course are lying to the American people
so much I've seen people you know with
the dislike button gone uh type in
comments dislike and that get a lot of
votes and people just commenting dislike
dislike dislike but but still it it
sucks that this voice has been taken
away because Netflix made a similar move
a couple years ago and I remember being
able to gauge if a Netflix series or
movie was good just by the ratings it
was I think it was one out of a hundred
Amy Schumer uh broke it and uh literally
just got rid of the system figuratively
not just her physical size but that's
beyond the point here and they got rid
of it because it broke the paradigms of
of what they wanted to be approved again
Netflix has a long history with a lot of
psychological manipulators I I that's a
whole different topic to get into but uh
I mean what is it with Dr fauci I mean
is is he really like this cult-like uh
Lord god-like figure I mean he they call
it the fouchy ouch yeah what's wrong
with it it's it's weird how this cult
developed around a guy there's there's
photos going around of protests from 30
years ago that say fauci lied and people
died and it was because of the the you
know the AIDS epidemic and all that
stuff and fauci's been around long
enough that people have hated him for
for Generations but somehow I posted I
posted this on Instagram actually let me
see if I can try and pull it up on
Instagram
no more Instagram interesting
let's try this again uh so there's a
meme about the left okay this is weird I
think I got it right here I just had to
go in a different way okay I don't know
huh here we go all right we got the meme
yeah it says old left versus modern left
on the left in the image you can see an
Old Hippie Volkswagen and it says you
know uh no CIA Free Speech free love
resist Authority Screw The Establishment
and then the right is a big SUV that
says do what you're told mask up heart
the CDC obey the establishment no free
speech huh 30 years ago they said fauci
was bad now the left they're all coming
out and they're like oh fouchy and
they're doing that thing remember that
dance they did where they spun and then
the big fouchy face popped up oh no
that's insane look look
I can understand if you're like hey man
we want everyone to get vaccinated and
we think we gotta work together to end
the pandemic I'm like okay I get it you
know you know some people have different
tolerances I personally believe in
freedom but that's a political argument
there but when you start pulling up
gigantic you know blankets that are huge
portraits of fauci in the street as you
sing and dance I'm like yo you're in a
cult yeah and then and then these people
are like no Donald Trump trump is the
cult and I'm like yeah I don't know
about all that because I'm not waving
Moga Flags or anything all I know is
y'all have a giant photo of fauci
spitting in the street and it's weird
the thing is about the Trump stuff we
went to a bar and they had that pick
that Meme picture of trump on the tank
and I'm like it's it's purposefully
ridiculous right these people are
self-aware that it's like I love it when
um Ben Garrison would make comics about
Trump he'd always be ripped incredible
like I'll admit some some people
absolutely are in that Trump cult no
joke but they're not institutionally
powerful this is like mainstream
corporate television late night shows
with giant fouchy banners singing and
dancing on that stuff you're not going
to get that from mainstream Libertarians
Independents or conservatives they are
legit in a cult
I of course with a portrait of himself
in his own office what was that to be
fair Joe Rogan bought up a really good
point he was like I don't know his
daughter maybe painted it for him and I
was like ah it's actually a really good
point like if your kid painted a
portrait of you you'd hang it up not
because it's you because your kid made
it for you but a little vain no no I
want to say no no I don't think so
because that someone sent us a picture
of me and someone who works here put it
up and I think it's kind of weird I'm
like ah it's a picture of me my face why
yeah yeah someone who works here put it
up yeah yeah but let me just say let me
say
I will not give fauci the benefit of the
doubt for hanging up a portrait of
himself in his own office that he works
beneath fauci seems like the kind of guy
who instructed someone to paint a
portrait of himself to put it yes you
know what I mean and to make Immaculate
and perfect and if there was an
imperfection he would whip the poor
painter immediately who didn't get his
likeness perfectly a painting of myself
in my office and don't spill any paint
droplets otherwise you'll ruin my work
amazing it's not just paintings it's
candles it's Christmas decorations
there's there's people getting tattoos
it's idol worship it's absolutely insane
I got one of those you know those
candles of like motor candles yeah
we someone brought one over with fauci's
head and Como Cuomo was also loved and
adored by the media just like fauci was
and and again you know you can't give
these people the benefit of the doubt
because of their behavior their real
life Behavior like Dr fauci in his real
life I mean Justin you you should talk
about this in a little bit it's not a
great person especially with the actions
that caused a lot of animal harm and
human harm but but more importantly here
he's publicly talking like he's God like
he's science let's let's yeah let's get
into the story we have this one from Tim
cast Ted Cruz Rand Paul fire back at
fauci over smug claim that he represents
science it's not the first time fauci
has done this and at what point do right
regular people just say yo this guy's
kind of an ego Maniac yes he's like I'm
the science okay well from tibgas.com an
interview with the Fate with Face the
Nation over the weekend fauci said
they're really criticizing science
because I represent science that's
dangerous my favorite thing about the
current state of the the modern left is
the um we believe in science people and
it's like you know I think Luke gave a
shirt that says that if you question it
at science if you can't it's propaganda
exactly and that's that's a really
that's it right there concise and to the
point science is literally questionable
science is literally to be criticized if
someone comes out says I'm a scientist I
say okay and they go you can't criticize
me and I'll say then you're not a
scientist because scientists actually
welcome challenges to their ideas to try
and better understand things fauci is
not that responding to fagi's claim on
Twitter senator Paul wrote the absolute
hubris of someone claiming they
represent science it's astounding and
alarming that a public health bureaucrat
would even think to claims to think
especially one who has worked so hard to
ignore the science of natural immunity
well I'll tell you this
fauci does represent science not all
science but he certainly represents a
gain of function research Reckless and
unethical and a moral experimentation to
make a chimeric coveted SARS viruses not
kovitz well no he changed the definition
of gain of function so yeah because he
is science yeah so he is science so he
changed the definition of gain of
function so now it's not gained a
function because he says so that would
be that'd be like a funny you know
cartoon where it's like the first humans
discover science they're digging in a
hole and they find like a book and then
all of a sudden once they come to the
realization of science fauci just
manifests in mid-air and he's like I am
born I am science and now like we don't
realize is actually like a 50 000 year
old manifestation of science itself and
we're criticizing him how dare dare we
yeah that makes sense but it's crazy I
mean his comments talking about how he's
science how he represents everything
that has to do with science and people
who criticize him are creating damage to
society by criticizing him in science I
mean are you kidding me what kind of
egomaniac do you have to be to say
anyone holding me accountable anyone
criticizing me of my decisions is
harming everyone else that's an
absolutely just totally insane thought
that people shouldn't have and it's
because he's been glorified he has so
much smoke up his family-friendly show
took us that I'm surprised he's not
flying in midair I mean this man had the
mainstream corporate media adore him and
he's only doing interviews with people
who don't question him people who adore
him people who of course live off every
word like it's gospel and he also
brought up January 6th which was
interesting because he said oh Ted Cruz
wants me arrested and then he like said
oh yeah what about January 6th and he
made this like weird slithering mouth
slippery tape
I released a video of that just on
replay like 10 times uh because it's
just so awkward and weird with him
getting so giddy about the idea of
January 6th no it was it was like
it was desperation yeah so he gets asked
by the interviewer she's like you know
Ted Cruz says you'd be prosecuted he
goes
Senator tell me about January 6th and I
was watching that and I was like oh what
about it like Ted Cruz was sitting in
the chambers apparently being threatened
by an angry mob so are you saying other
people were threatening Ted Cruz because
Ted Cruz was like in there you know
talking and then had to be evacuated
with everybody else is is is was that
was that it like is that fauci's play
like wow you know Trump and January 6.
it's like yeah I don't think Ted Cruz
anything to do with that so your point
yeah but let's not forget this man also
lied about so many aspects of what was
happening here he changed his mind he
keeps continuing to flip-flop without
any dose of kind of reality of saying
hey I made a mistake here has he ever
done that he has has he ever came out
and said hey I I was wrong before
um I this is my admission I haven't seen
one uh he hasn't been talking about a
lot of the other important stuff that a
lot of other medical professionals have
been talking about all around the world
so I mean how far does this go back I
mean Justin I think I think you would
know more about this like how far has he
been calling the shots in a way where
it's kind of been affecting people and
animals in in such a disastrous way well
I mean it goes back 40 years from you
know where my interest is as
taxpayer-funded animal experimentation I
mean fauci
ushered in the modern era of uh
experimenting on primates particularly
chimpanzees I mean he was the biggest
championing of that he created a massive
colony of chimps that he was infecting
with HIV back in the late 80s and early
90s saying that this was going to be the
Silver Bullet for AIDS vaccine that we
just had to infect enough chimps with
HIV Well turns out they don't get AIDS a
couple of gotten AIDS they didn't get
sick it was a complete failure he never
acknowledged that of course we ended up
with these chimps who were just
warehoused for decades and abuse because
fauci had created this problem but he we
don't have an HIV and AIDS vaccine after
40 Years of fauci promising one year
after year I mean they're still doing
experiments on primates now for HIV AIDS
promising every year oh we have a
breakthrough here's the vaccine that's
gonna you know that's going to protect
everyone we still don't have one and
that's a side I mean 40 years that's
aside from what he's doing now to dogs
and primates like Tim Cass has been
covering with Monkey Island yeah we'll
get into Monkey Island in a second but
also you know I'd like to say about uh
fouching them you know you made a great
Point Luke about the media feeding his
ego I mean I was doing an interview with
the Washington Post a few weeks ago they
were working on a hit piece about us
because we've been criticizing fauci and
they straight up asked me do you think
you don't you think you criticizing
fauci for paying for the torture of dogs
is hurting his ability to do covet
response
those two things are completely
unrelated what did you say I said I
don't know of anyone not getting wearing
a mask or getting a vaccine because
we're criticizing him for torturing dogs
and they seem shocked about that how
you started questions like uh fauci's
the head of the niaid he funds a lot of
research beyond all of this yeah like
what okay can you can you I'm asking us
like literally yeah can you name
something the naaid funds that's not
gain a function and not animal research
it's hard I mean they probably fun more
animal research than any other agency
the reason I ask is uh there certainly
are things that are funded that aren't
gain of function and that aren't animal
research and uh I don't know if you know
I know your specialty is specifically on
the animal stuff but for someone to ask
you like aren't you concerned you
criticizing fouchy over animal research
is hurting his ability to work on covid
and it's like I don't know is it hurting
his ability to develop like you know
something like to do other research on
other other areas like is it affecting
his plant research yeah is it affecting
his fish research I I look if if fauci
is doing research on like you know
viruses and biology and plants why
aren't you asking me that question oh oh
no what about crop yield you're coming
and talking about covet I get it it's
it's but fauci is the head of an entire
you know uh this department so see so of
course
I guess you know criticizing him in one
area will have an impact on everything
he does if they want to give him credit
for all of the great that they say he's
doing then he also has to accept blame
for the evil that happening under his
watch also that's you know that's just
the reality of it but they don't want to
accept that instead they want to try to
delegitimize the critics which is what
they've been trying to do to us and it's
it's it's a stupid argument I mean I
understand that a lot of people on the
right will certainly be like wow
fouchie's a bad dude when they see him
doing bad things but I think that's
independent it's in and of itself if
fauci does bad things you call him out
for it if people right now are really
concerned about fauci because of the
gain of function research and the lying
to Congress over and over again then I
think people have a reason to be like
what other bad things has this guy done
hey that sounds really bad too here's
the other thing you know we talk a lot
about animal research but like I don't
know there's probably a whole bunch of
other stuff I can't even think of or
they probably do a ton of really awful
crazy stuff I'm seeing one article here
by NPR that talks about how NIH tested
aged drugs on foster children
this is NPR May 27 2005 NIH tested AIDS
drugs on foster children and a lot of
people are saying that Dr fauci was the
one responsible behind that
allegedly online so I'm seeing a lot of
talk about this as well have you seen
anything uh yeah oh yeah we got it here
it is from NPR holy cow na NIH tested
AIDS drugs on foster children so you
know these are Big stories that a lot of
people don't really recognize in the 80s
and 90s that was fauci wasn't it yeah
yeah yeah so it's not just animals it's
not just monkeys it's it's not just you
know
there's there's so much to get into
especially when it comes to the the kind
of effects that is all being done in the
name of helping people that really
bothers a lot of people's minds wait
wait let me read this from CBS News the
research funded by the NIH span the
country it was most widespread in the
90s as foster care agencies sought
treatments for HIV infected children
that weren't available in the
marketplace the practice ensured that
foster children mostly poor or minority
received care from world-class
researchers at government expense
slowing their rate of death and
extending their lives but it also
exposed a vulnerable population the
risks of medical research and drugs that
were known to have serious side effects
in adults and for which the safety of
children was unknown I love that really
warm thing it's like we were
experimenting on children yeah and it
was world class experimentation
yeah they didn't have any adult
Advocates so they you know tested them
which is just mind-boggling and should
of course raise a lot of concerns this
should be a bigger story a lot of people
should understand this no I'm sorry in
one study researchers reported a
disturbing higher death rate among
children who took higher doses of a drug
that study was unable to determine a
safe and effective dosage yo they
straight up killed kids oh my God that's
that's what it's saying the drugs they
gave them resulted in a higher death
rate yeah all in the name of Dr fauci
conducting his scientific experiments yo
here's your answer from now on if you
ever ask anything like that if they're
like are you concerned you're hurting
his work on you know treating kova and
be like well I mean if it's also hurting
his work on say giving dangerous
experimental AIDS drugs to children that
results in a high rate of death it's
probably a good thing to foster children
and orphans who don't have any adult
representations
so fauci is a white supremacist indeed
looks like Dr Fox can't give consent
that's true gave foster kids who can't
consent drugs that result in a higher
rate of death and they were minority
children because fauci is a white
supremist that's something that the
Democrats and a lot of power
establishments can't get through their
heads that one particular phrase kids
can't consent
um and again I got a lot more to say
that about that when it comes to the
Maxwell some foster children died during
studies but state or city agency said
they could find no records at any deaths
were directly caused by experimental
treatments what
yeah did you ever look into that Justin
or uh not that specifically but I mean
we deal with the same I mean we also
deal with the same crappy reporting that
we're seeing here where everything is
cushioned with some lovely phrase about
how well-meaning the NIH is but then we
killed kids I mean the the fauci
recently paid for dogs to have their
vocal cords cut so they couldn't bark in
the lab and then the sentence after that
was well it was a little too loud for
they don't want to hurt the eardrums of
the experimenters in the uh that that
famous the big story that went viral the
Beagle story yeah they had the beagles
their heads in boxes with were they
sandflies or something and they had to
snip the vocal cords of the dogs because
the the agony of the dogs were in they'd
be screaming and writhing so they're
like just set their vocal cords so we
can't hear it yeah make it all go away
there's a a short film a series of short
films put out by Neil blomkamp I think
his name is and uh one of the first one
is about like aliens come to Earth and
you start harvesting cities and building
up and terraforming and they treat
humans like cattle or whatever and it
just shows like how they experiment on
humans it was it was an idea I had a
long time ago about like if an advanced
species came here how would they treat
us the funny thing is my initial idea
was like aliens come to Earth they slice
buildings in half and rip the copper
wiring out and just Harvest it like we
would a tree or any other mineral and
then I realized that um it doesn't need
to be aliens when people do it it
doesn't need to be aliens doing the
stuff when the the billionaire Elites
the the political class treat human
beings like a cattle like chickens you
know in a chicken coop humans do it to
each other
let's let's talk about what uh what Dr
fauci is doing here with the story we've
had from Tim cast the story actually
went up earlier this month
a couple weeks ago
exclusive fauci's niaid funding island
of monkeys in South Carolina used for
horrific maximum pain experiments it's a
report by Cassandra Fairbanks with
sourcing from white coat waste project
Dr Anthony fauci and the National
Institutes of Health are using an island
off the coast of South Carolina to breed
monkeys for use in horrific maximum pain
animal experimentation and I must state
I hate doing this but I had to remove
the images from the article because I
can't show them on YouTube because
they're graphic but this is what fauci's
niad is funding and I have to wonder why
it is so do you want to break down for
us what this this primate Island stuff
is what is fauci doing sure so this is
It's called Morgan Island it's off the
coast of South Carolina there's in
fiscal year 20 there was
3521 monkeys on this island and each
year they take about five or six hundred
of them into fauci's Labs fauci owns the
monkeys fauci's division owns these
three thousand five hundred now hold on
is this fouchy like as an individual
pointing the finger and saying I want
these monkeys moved or is it like him
signing off on a grant and then throwing
it into a pile
um it's unclear we have foia requests in
to see what his degree of knowledge is
about this directly but it's been in the
news a lot over the years the fact that
this place exists
um he probably knows about it it's a big
program of theirs it's where they get
most of their monkeys he's signing off
on the grants to run as the Director
yeah that's right so it'll be
interesting to find out to what degree
of his involvement is but uh yeah carry
on tell me what's going on
um so they take about five or six
hundred of these monkeys off the island
each year bring them to the labs in
Bethesda and Maryland
um and then they expose them to
infectious diseases uh including covid
uh including HIV AIDS including NEPA
virus lhasa lots of lots of illnesses
that no one in the United States has
ever gotten
um and then that sounds really dangerous
it's dangerous and it's also is that how
the NIH should be spending our money on
you know when there's plenty of
neglected diseases that are hurting
people I mean our position is that the
taxpayers should not be funding any of
this all at all and the private sector
should fund it if it's so important yeah
um so these experiments involve you know
creating diseases that are causing
monkeys pain hemorrhaging multi-organ
failure brain damage and then they
completely withhold any pain relief
because they don't want it to interfere
with their experiment that's looking on
how these diseases progress so some of
these experiments are just to see what
happens when you create a monkey model
of these horrible infectious diseases
and then so that we call them maximum
pain experiments because they're
classified as causing significant pain
and distress and then intentionally
withholding the pain relief and just
watching these monkeys slowly die or
quickly die depending on why why so
they're doing it because they're like we
want to know what happens with this
disease we want to see how it reminds me
of uh I don't want to you know equate
humans and animals to to a great degree
I certainly think primates as you know a
higher intelligent species there's
degrees to which we're willing to
tolerate torture of animals and
experimentation but it does remind me
um well I'll start here first I was just
saying how Elites treat us like chicken
like cattle like like you know just
fodder and we had what was it unit uh
Unit 731 741 yeah 741 do you know the
Japanese experimental unit in World War
II they would take that like one one
example is they took a person and they
stuck their hand in like Sub-Zero
temperatures so it would freeze and they
shattered it to see what would happen
and then you had the Nazi scientists
they were basically I wonder what will
happen if I did this to a person now
interestingly they say that we a lot of
a lot of the stuff we know about
frostbite comes from these inhumane
human experiment experiments and I'm
like
you know at a certain point my attitude
towards freezing to death and losing
limbs is kind of like we know you'll
lose your limb and you'll freeze to
death if you uh are exposed and how
about we reckon we we just have to
reconcile the fact that our knowledge of
hypothermia must come through uh
emergency accidents like if you want to
learn about frostbite it's going to be
due to the fact that someone got lost in
the cold and you're bringing them into
the hospital to save them and watching
what's happening not subjecting them
these experiments in this case maybe Pro
maybe scientific progress shouldn't be
sped up by the fact that we're taking
primates that we breed on an island to
basically torture just to see what
happens and the point is is it's not
sped up by doing this right so our our
name you know white coat refers to the
experimenters in their white lab coats
and then waste is a reference to the
fact that the NIH on its own website
admits that 9 out of 10 drugs that pass
animal tests fail in human beings
because they don't work or they're
dangerous so we have 20 billion dollars
a year spent on animal experimentation
we know that it's failing 90 to 95 to
alzheimer's for example Alzheimer's
drugs over 99 failure rate so it's an
incredible waste of money there's
there's very little return on investment
for taxpayers which is why we think that
if this stuff is so important Let The
Gates Foundation fund it but we know
that there are not private foundations
that are going to fund a lot of the
stuff because it's completely wasteful
it's irrelevant and it's not going to
help anybody what is it just lining
people's pockets with gold oh yeah it's
big money I mean universities are taking
25 off the top just for administrative
fees and then you've got experimenters
driving nice cars and living in gated
communities and it's it's big business
you've got the companies that make the
cages that breed the animals that you
know there's a company that runs Monkey
Island and they have a 13 and a half
million dollar contract so we went and
saw Ghostbusters afterlife
thought it was fantastic great movie and
then um the next day I was like oh let's
watch the original Ghostbusters the
original Ghostbusters is about three
University professors who are up doing
paranormal research operating off a
grant and then the dean comes in and
says we're shutting down your Grant and
all of a sudden they're like what do we
do there's a scene where Dan Aykroyd is
talking to Bill Murray and he says you
don't know what it's like in the private
sector out there they demand results in
here you get grant money you sit around
and do nothing
and I I reminded of that because that's
it yeah there are people who are
probably sitting there and they're
they're their field of research is you
know um nerves and like pain and stuff
like that and they're like I don't know
what to research
let's just get a bunch of badgers and
beat them or something I don't know and
then they get a grant and then they get
hundreds of thousands of dollars to the
grant the university gets their cut they
get paid a six-figure salary they get to
drive their nice car in their gated
community and just like hey we hit a
gopher with a hammer and it died that's
what we learned I mean I'm obviously
exaggerating but you're not not far
you're not that far not that far off no
I mean universities are corrupt man yeah
I mean we're sure we're we're paying for
monkeys to get addicted to nicotine and
crack and cocaine at some at
universities I mean that's really
happening somebody was like uh I uh will
take monkeys and give them uh crack yeah
yes and then the guy was like done
stamps it signs over the grant where
does the Grant come from the government
it's taxpayer funded all of this is
taxpayer funded you got rodents smoking
jewels
you've got uh What jewels like like
vaping the douche flutes wait wait
rodents vaping vaping they build Special
vaping Chambers just for mice and rats
and then they put literal Jewels not
some lab created off-brand I actually
use Jewel brand can you just imagine
being like a researcher and you're like
at a party and you've got like your
elbow patches or whatever and there's
like you're this dude this hot chicks
like so what do you do it's like I give
Vapes to rats like wait what yeah we
have rats they vape and she's like what
it's my job yeah we we have uh rats Vape
that's a really weird job I really doubt
there's a like I'm these guys like do
they lie about their jobs because I
can't imagine that impresses anybody
like they're at their High School
reunion and one guy's like you know I
was a captain of the high school
football team and I'm actually coaching
a college you know a small College in
you know Missouri and it's like oh wow
that's actually pretty good one guy's
like I'm actually you know a senior vice
president a marketing firm wow and what
about you I give Vapes to rats
so this is a classic case of um the
supply exceeding the demand or whatever
you know it's a little bit like racism
they're looking for it everywhere they
can't find it they have to make it up if
you give people a bunch of money like
literally unlimited money for grants for
this nonsense they're gonna do stuff
like CF rats know how to vape and all
that spend a bunch of money on it I
don't know why that one to me is just
like I'm just imagining South Park doing
a bit about like a rat walking up and
just vaping because it's like it's the
perfect real world scenario that's right
for parody and it's pure absurdity like
why are we doing that people humans are
vaping we can ask them to come into the
university and we have them answer
questions and then do a physical and we
have data on people yeah and we know
that you know for years the connection
between Cancer and smoking cigarettes
was obscured because the tobacco
companies were relying on animal
research and they're saying oh no it's
fine animals don't get sick from smoking
cigarettes and now we're doing this
making the same mistake over again
mistake or intentional yeah yeah we
gotta do more aspartame research too and
it's I I don't know Donald Rumsfeld
favorite uh uh particle but Justin how
much is this how much of this is
scientific research how much of this is
just cruelty
I mean I I'd argue that all it ranges
from the stupid to the sadistic right so
what's happening on Monkey Island I
think most people think is sick and
shouldn't be happening and then you have
uh last week with Senator Joni Ernst for
Thanksgiving we highlighted putting
turkeys on treadmills which was taxpayer
funded wait wait why to see if domestic
turkeys uh ran faster than wild turkeys
why do we need to know do that why is
that I don't remember
another question now we got a very
serious threat from China and if we're
talking you know like land ground combat
and like a land war in Asia maybe we
need to understand which turkeys can
carry the the Weaponry into the field
either for combat or to bring supplies
hey maybe we get a turkey and we put a
first aid kit him and we let them lose
cybernetics and we're gonna yes and we
need to know which turkey is going to
run fast I gotta Miss I have no
um it may just be
let me put it this way there's probably
some turkey researcher who's sitting in
his office right now smoking a cigar
going like these idiots yes no idea and
he's got like this top secret document
about like turkey research and he's
discovered something in Turkey muscle
cells yeah and it's possible we just
don't understand something about turkeys
on treadmills but I think they need to
justify that like they need they need to
explain the goal of letting us
understand why a turkey runs faster than
another turkey because I got to be
honest I got a 410 for turkey hunting
and I don't think it matters how fast
the turkey runs
they're like the race are just completed
and now we're including a warning label
on all 410 turkey load that says lead
the target slightly more if it's a wild
turkey compared to a domestic release
turkey that's what's for yep like it's
paid for by gun companies and that would
be fine let them pay for it let the
poultry producers pay for it to see who
the fastest turkey is
um
there's like the research is because
some dude has like underground turkey
races
is using Government funding to try and
get an edge against us he like flies to
Mexico and they're like run vamos the
turkeys are running I can't imagine
Optical turkeys
Justin did you see any of these papers
and and think hey this actually does
make sense I actually do want to know
about this this actually does benefit
Humanity did you ever see any of those
particular studies yourself
um sure I've seen interesting questions
that have been asked
um but the question for me then comes
back to what is the cost to animals
uh which I'm concerned about and then
what is the cost of taxpayers is this
something we should we should be bearing
the burden of especially when we know
how inefficient it is and you know to go
back to your point about uh University
Research versus private research I mean
there's no incentive in taxpayer-funded
animal research to innovate or to solve
a problem because the second you solve
the problem the money gets cut off so
the actual the incentive is to keep
going and going and going and not solve
the problem and just Tinker until you
retire that's how the government works
and that's how big Pharma works and the
prison industrial complex and the
military industrial conflicts
work yeah most non-profits like they
don't want to solve their problems
because then
they go out of business yeah but that's
why I think you know a lot of This
research is just a guy sitting there
being like I need a proposal otherwise
I'm broke so let me just write up
whatever I can and you know get it
approved and I mean to your point that
you made earlier I mean some of it you
know you asked about the point of some
of this I mean some of it is just
tinkering at Great expense to humanity
to like gain a function where you're
just trying to take a naturally
occurring virus and see if you can make
it more dangerous it seems like a lot of
the gain of function stuff was literally
just we need something because you you
either you either can you look you look
at their official explanation oh we did
gain a function so that in the event
this virus emerged we'd have a vaccine
for we could research it and it's like
what are the what's the likelihood of a
virus like that would emerge are you
literally going to make 50 billion
different viruses hoping that one of
them that's ridiculous
so then it just sounds like they're
either trying to weaponize it or they're
just bored and like I'll do whatever if
you give me a grant I guess
considering how fauci circumvented the
ban and like changed the definition
definitions and tried to weasel his way
through this sounds more like they were
just trying to make weapons
it could be I mean Eco Health Alliance
the intermediary the non-profit that was
taking the money and sending it to the
Wuhan Institute of virology it's a U.S
non-profit and actually uh Waco waste
was the group that we exposed the link
between the NIH and the Wuhan Institute
of virology that that money was passing
through
um
they were also applying for money from
DARPA for the from the dod to do gain a
function research and DARPA denied them
saying this was too dangerous and they
hadn't taken proper precautions to
protect against causing a pandemic so
going to China would very LAX safety
protocols and the Chinese government
looking over the the shoulders of every
scientist there's definitely the smart
reasonable thing to do by of course Mr
science man and Peter dazek Peter dazek
the bat lady I mean when you delve into
and do research into them holy cow you
find out a lot of quote very interesting
stuff that we can't even get into on
this show but when you we're really
looking to these people all the warning
signs are there on the wall I mean I
don't know how much research you've done
into those individuals as well uh but
but is there anything you could say uh
personally yourself from your research
about what they have been up to what
they have been involved in I mean Peter
dashik has connections to the Chinese
Communist party going back decades yep
literally he's a darling of theirs which
is why they gave him Acts s which is why
they let him in there which is why they
took his money and which is why they let
him come in and do gain of function
experiments that maybe could be used for
whatever purposes that they could use
that a military or a rising power that
wants to challenge an existing power
might potentially use again we're
getting into the hypothetical here
we're speculating a little bit which we
need to talk about clearly but with the
information that we got I don't think
it's too far of a stretch to exhibit
some of those ideas or to examine some
of those ideas under a critical point of
view I'm speaking of course very well
listen I think it it would be naive to
ignore the fact that the Wuhan Institute
of virology is run by the Communist
party and that is ties to the pla it
doesn't mean that what they were doing
was intended to be weaponized
necessarily but what they were doing was
incredibly dangerous
and something that we weren't allowed to
be done here
and that the Chinese Communist party is
bending over backwards to cover up and
you know they've deleted the database
with their virus database that might
lead us to whether they had a virus that
was like
the coven 19. they deleted that in
September 2019. the researchers at the
Wuhan Institute of virology got sick
with covert-like symptoms in November
2019. the wife of a researcher at the
wuhan's do virology died apparently in
December 2019 before all of that at the
Wuhan military game so that was
apparently one of the original Super
spreader events
so everything points to the fact that
this Laboratory
is at the epicenter of the pandemic here
and there's literally no evidence that
this thing came out of nature naturally
other than the fact that other pandemics
have started that way
there have been so the challenge is if
you're a Layman you're reading the news
their reports they do say that the wet
Market natural emergence Theory makes
the most sense but I think I'll just go
to Jon Stewart on Colbert's Show when he
was like you have the Wuhan lab that
does experiments on SARS viruses and
then a SARS virus emerges just that just
you know on the across the street from
the Wuhan lab and they say the the virus
may have originated you know a thousand
miles away or something it's like Jon
Stewart was a little more exuberant in
his presentation of this but the way I
describe it is it's like you find you
know somebody laying on the ground face
down with you know a bruise on the back
of their head and someone's standing
over them holding a bat and you're going
to be like hmm there's no evidence to
suggest this person hit this other
person so I don't know it's a
speculation guys the best theory is the
guy just fell down yeah walking and he
fell down and that's it it's like I I
mean I think it's fair to speculate can
we go look at the cameras Oh I'm sorry
the cameras have all been deleted and
destroyed about that and the guy who was
leading the investigation is actually
friends with the guy with the baseball
bat
he's funded okay so we got a problem and
he's censoring all the information about
this entire incident and how it unfolded
huh interesting it reminds me of that
Family Guy Joe where the the bar burns
down and then the new owner gets all
that insurance money and then uh I guess
the the main character's wives ask the
insurance guy they're like don't you
think it's a little weird that he took
out an insurance policy for a fire and
then had a fire the next day and the
insurance guy goes no actually it
happens all the time huh it's like don't
you think it's a little weird what's
happening with the Wuhan virus the news
reports the the refusal to do to release
the data and the the genome and stuff
and it's just like are we supposed to
sit back and be like this is normal when
it's very clearly not and they're trying
to stop us from investigating what
happened at the lab at that point it's
like look I am the science yeah I
understand I am if there's if there's a
virus SARS covet virus that emerges next
to a lab that research has on and does
chimeric you know experimentation the
creation of chimeric SARS viruses
it's the most ridiculous thing in the
world to be like but it probably came
across the street from the wet market
and they've tested 80 000 animal samples
haven't found a single animal who had
SARS cov2
um yet you have these viruses that are
more than 96 identical in the you know
that they were experimenting on and
trying to supercharge they're in Wuhan
well now we got on the crown yeah Joe
Biden says that if we don't need to I
love this the headlines are like Joe
Biden says no lockdown necessary and I
was like yeah that's what they said in
January or whatever Joe Biden was like
we're not going to be logging down doing
mandates and then you actually get to
the middle of the story where they bury
the lead and he actually said for now
if everyone gets vaccinated and wears
masks then they won't be necessary
and then there's this video of
University of Michigan I guess football
game running out of the field tens of
thousands of people and I'm like yo
people are not going to follow these
rules they're saying no to this now
they're saying daily basis an article
that says we screwed up this is really a
three dose vaccine Bill Maher already
came out and said I took one for the
team I got my shots I got two I'm not
doing it again and I'm like the CDC says
the definition of fully vaccinated will
change to accommodate three shots The
Daily Beast is saying it's actually a
three-shot vaccine so now if you only
have two you're not fully vaccinated so
Joe Biden's gonna have no choice but to
be like look come on man you know people
don't get vaccinated so we got to lock
down to save lives I think it's going to
be another lockdown like it was last
year I think you're right Joe Biden has
this habit of doing this thing where he
goes we will all have unity and we will
all get along if you do exactly what I
tell you to do and I'm like how is that
Unity we're not getting along for just
doing what you tell us to do this was
what I was talking about earlier with
elitism he thinks he knows exactly
what's right for everyone so just gonna
say this is how it's going to be and if
you don't do as I say you're going to be
locked down again and you can go screw
yourself because I'm in charge which is
not the way the US was originally
intended to run this is not how it's
supposed to be but we've gradually
stepped up what a president can do and
say
um and it's
bad it's crazy what's going on in
Australia you see what's going on in
Australia with the lockdowns no so uh
the amount of insanity that's directed
my way over this is La it's hilarious uh
I I got I got like text messages from
people like yo what's going on like
people are talking about you and I was
like I tweeted that the quarantine camps
where I was hyperbolic I said
concentration camp in a tweet and all of
a sudden they're screaming at the top of
their lungs and so someone tweeted a
video of the minister of the I believe
it's the Northeast territories in
Australia I don't know a lot about
Australia but their politics government
States and or whatever they call them
provinces or States I think they're
States but he basically said that's you
know I'd like to thank the ADF which is
the Australian military the Australian
Defense Force for helping transport
suspected coveted cases and close
contacts to the Howard Springs facility
he also said in that statement that
they're removing the five reasons for
leaving your home the five reasons were
exercise work medical reasons getting
food or you know if you order something
and he's like this means they no longer
have the five reasons and they can only
leave for emergency medical procedures
to put it mildly if you live in these
areas they have announced you can't
leave your home to eat
then they say they're transporting these
people to the Howard Springs quarantine
facility which I guess is a first I
believe where they've been relocating
internal Australians to these quarantine
camps
and then all of a sudden on Twitter the
whole narrative becomes is it voluntary
and all these Australian personalities
are either saying Tim's a conspiracy
theorist because I quote it it's
literally in the Guardians the guardian
article wrote this or they're like well
Tim to be fair there's no evidence it's
forced and I was like
let me get this straight
you send to the military you tell them
to their faces you can't leave your home
to eat and then you say but if you'd
like to voluntarily come with us to a
quarantine facility we'll give you food
that's not force there's no scenario in
which they are not forcefully relocating
indigenous people and these are people
who don't even have coven they're close
contacts there's numerous stories about
people desperately trying to escape the
quarantine facilities one woman set fire
to a room forcing an evacuation one
woman jumped the fence and like ran off
and got caught and then fined five
thousand dollars so it does not seem
people are too happy to be there yeah
there's also crazy footage of police
officers and security guards running up
to people because someone dared to put
one foot outside of their perimeter Zone
that they were allowed to be in outside
of their holding cells I mean there's
also allegations of forced vaccination
by some of the indigenous people in
Australia there's also record waves of
protests hitting the streets of Sydney
hitting the streets of Melbourne I mean
some of the videos and it's so crazy
that we're not even hearing anything
about this mass movement this Mass
Awakening of hundreds of thousands of
people hitting the streets not just in
Italy not just in Melbourne but in
Guadalupe as well there's so many places
around the world that just are saying
hey we believe in natural rights we
believe in human rights you shouldn't be
taking this away from us in the name of
this emergency
and still there's there's not really a
mention of this which is absolutely
mind-boggling for me personally to say
the least I think lockdowns are coming
yeah for a lot of reasons we're seeing
it in Europe uh Australia just
implemented another lockdown they were
like we're using lockdowns they're like
oh no I'm a crown got you omocron got
here and people are like how did Omicron
get into Australia if you can't enter
unless you're vaccinated and you can't
even leave unless you're vaccinated well
it's because Omicron apparently is a
variant is less likely to be stopped by
the vaccine I suppose so sounds like
everything Australia is doing isn't
stopping anything because they're going
nuts with it yeah in the U.S I think
we'll follow Europe suit you know your
Europe's uh what Europe is doing all
these different you know European
countries I think that the United States
is you're gonna see more and more blue
States come up with excuses why they
need reinstate the lockdowns bring it
all back and conveniently right around
an election year midterm elections are
going to be very important and they're
going to do everything in their power in
my opinion to try and fortify the
election
well Israel and Japan just closed their
borders to All Foreign visitors
um Israel also just announced that
they're using their intelligence
agencies to have temporary permission to
gain access into the phone data of
people who were in the countries with
confirmed omnicron variant cases so
again there's nothing temporary about
these new laws and rules that they're
implementing but for them to use the
National Security State Israeli
intelligence agencies to hunt down and
to contact Trace people who were in a
country with cases in the name of
security is is just absolutely
mind-boggling and the opposite of
security in my opinion you see Ryan
Long's sketch about being pro profiser
he was like my pronouns are fizy what do
you say fizier or whatever I thought
that was really good but he basically
walks around he talks about how he's
like it's a skin but he's like I used to
be a leftist and I was you know against
all the big Pharma and of course I don't
like Martin shkreli but Pfizer is
different oh yeah I got the Pfizer
vaccine and he walks up to a guy and
this is interesting um the first thing I
always say about this stuff is like look
I get it you know if you go talk to your
doctor figure out what makes sense for
you we're not here to give you advice on
that stuff but he in this Ryan long
video he walks up to a random guy in the
street and he's like are you a Pfizer
guy and the guy's like oh yeah he's like
I got all three man I'm in for three and
he and then and then Ryan's like oh yeah
you're gonna go four and five he goes
I'm gonna do all of them and I'm just
like wow
yeah and those are average day people
just saying yes I'm gonna comply uh
meanwhile um South Africa is also
reporting no major uptick in cases
they're reporting mild cases the
scientists who discovered this new
variant publicly came out and talked to
the BBC and said people are panicking
unnecessarily so that we still don't
know what's going on here again I'm not
a medical doctor I'm not a medical
professional we're not here giving you
medical advice but I think it's fair to
say that we're in a position where we
don't know what's happening and I think
we shouldn't be jumping to conclusions
or spreading fear at the same time which
doesn't help anyone stresses people out
and actually lowers system actually
people can uh I don't know if somebody
wants to looks up someone super chatted
that Dan bongino had got a breakthrough
case of covet because he's vaccinated
and that he took the Rogan cocktail oh
it's crazy to me that I can have a
doctor
say go to sleep and sleep it off and
then me be like I would like a second
opinion and then call another doctor
says let's give you the full run
and then the media be like Tim's dumb
for listening to his doctor I'm like
what was I supposed to do no doc this is
what I tweeted I was like my doctor says
I should take you know this medicine but
Don Lemon says it's a bad idea and of
course Don Lemon knows better than my
doctor yeah that's that's the reality
we're supposed to be living in yeah CNN
can't do wrong they're they're uh you
know holy and everyone should listen to
them and they should all be recommended
to everyone's YouTube searches and you
know they're so innocent and loving and
daily Daily Beast wrote an article it
said Tim Poole is a new poster boy for
Ivermectin and the reason they chose
that headline is specifically because I
have not promoted it and actually talked
about how I told my doctor I didn't want
it and that I I was like I feel better
and I want to take it and they
instructed me you have to like we're
prescribing this you should do it and I
was like I don't want it and I ended up
taking it anyway but they say poster boy
because if they said I promoted it or
was Shilling for it like that that'd be
a false statement of fact poster boy is
a meaningless opinion statement that
can't be deciphered properly you know
what they're trying to claim they're
trying to make it seem like I'm out
there like I went on Joe Rogan's show
and I actually still argued with him
about it not like a strong argument
because I'm not a doctor and I really
don't know but I was just like I don't
know man I think I think this stuff's
challenging when you've got political
sides and they're making arguments about
stuff some people just want to believe
it works some people don't want to
believe it works and I think it's fair
to say there are some studies that are
very positive there are some aggregate
studies that are you know um
indeterminate but really it just comes
down to what your doctor offers you so
for me it's like if my attitude is
slightly towards the negative like you
know people say they don't approve it
because
um they don't make money off it and I'm
like if Merck manufactures this stuff
sure they can make more money something
proprietary but they could easily get
emergency use authorization for this if
they wanted to so maybe there's a profit
incentive or something I don't know but
if I call a doctor and the doctor is
like we're giving you you know zabodine
or something I'm not gonna be alive whoa
whoa doc like I don't know that word
sounds weird I just be like okay I'll
look into it and you know we'll see if
it makes sense for me and then if when
it comes to Ivermectin I know little bit
more about it I was like the monoclonal
antibodies did me right and I feel I
feel totally fine and they were like no
we prescribed it for you and I said okay
doc whatever you say yeah isn't that the
attitude the left says you're supposed
to have like the establishment left
trust your doctor trust the science but
when I literally do that they write
smear articles about me
and and I wish this wasn't so political
I mean even the naming of this variant
has been political it's it's it's the
World Health Organization skipping the
Greek alphabet in order to appease
someone with a similar name z uh what
yeah they skipped that one yeah so the
ony Krab variant should have been called
the Z variant yeah yeah x i but no way
yeah but the World Health Organization
skipped it and before I call it the she
variant yeah
so so again when you have such
politicization when you have so many
people uh benefiting off of this you
should be able to ask questions you
should be able to have an open
discussion and we can't and a lot of the
discussion is being hindered a lot of
the conversation is being stopped a lot
of the debate a lot of scientists are
even being hindered and that's
absolutely a nonsensical start in many
people's minds and if you want to
convince them you want to win hearts and
Minds start with an open honest
conversation we don't even have that
let's call it the you know we have the
lemon variant yes well uh the next one
will be who should get it next Selter or
Cuomo the Cuomo variant yeah Cooper the
Cooper variant just all of CNN excuse me
the Vanderbilt variant
yeah why is his name Anderson Cooper is
because his mom didn't change her name
or what um I have no idea I didn't I I
didn't really do that much research into
it but he was raised by the Vanderbilts
and uh also attended a very interesting
um after school programs in college
let's just double down on it because
they try tried skipping over the she
variant we'll call it the Xi Jinping
variant yeah I like that that's good we
just literally name it after him well no
it's not a compromise it's just doubling
down like oh you want to not say she
will add the Jinping to it just to go
straight for it well how about we go to
super chats if you haven't already smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
and uh share the show with your friends
go to timcast.com be a member one of the
members only segment coming up in just a
little bit and I'm going to type smash
the like button right now in the chat
hold on enter it in we got the Lubin
tube invariant as well
the Lubin tuben variant did that work
okay it worked all right we're gonna
read some super chats and see what uh
what people have to say Gerald Armstrong
says remember when Jesse's Millet was in
the Mighty Ducks is that true he was I
think he might have been I know his
sister was an actress too yeah she was
in the Great Debaters
yes that ruins my all-time favorite
movie
look it up I'm looking it up yeah yeah
according to IMDb was wow they got to
bring it they got to bring it back 1992.
I love the Justin Smollett story just
it's like because it was so dumb
growing up in Chicago the area where he
claimed to have been attacked like I
would I've been there so many times
people don't live there for the most
part so he's just like this this d-list
celebrity at 3 A.M or 2 A.M getting a
sub sandwich and two Trump supporters in
Chicago for some reason because this guy
was deep blue in freezing weather in the
hours of the morning happened to spot
him while they're carrying a noose and a
hot sauce bottle full of bleach and mega
hats with mega hats on it who then yell
it's Maga country and and throw the news
on his neck and splash him with bleach
or whatever and I'm just like and fight
them no fight and he fought them off he
fought two two of them off and beat him
up so amazing yeah well they also dyro
Brothers I guess are going to be
testifying against them so it's gonna be
good to that yeah Restless medic says
Tim thanks for being consistent in your
advocacy for gun rights it definitely
helps change Minds to see a former
anti-gun or see reason I was never an
anti-goner though my ad well I guess
technically you'd say that my attitude
initially was just born out of ignorance
of kind of like maybe we can have a
reasonable discussion about you know uh
proper distribution but people should be
allowed to have gone Second Amendment
and then someone commented then I think
we should be able to have some
reasonable discussion about limits on
your on your free speech because that's
also in the Constitution and I was like
I get your point okay if you want to
change gun laws you got to change the
Constitution first end of story so
that's basically my position for the
most part I certainly think you know
there are issues there was a story I was
reading today about a dad who killed his
daughter they were out hunting whitetail
deer and he was unloading his gun at his
truck when it it went off and hit his 11
year old daughter they transported to
the hospital she didn't make it the
comments were all basically like he
screwed up there's no way that could
happen if he was taking proper care of
his firearm and I struggled to imagine a
scenario in which that would be a wrong
statement like he was pointing the
weapon at his daughter while he was
unloading it like come on man
or it was a freak accident Ricochet or
his daughter was 11 and did something
dumb but when you when when you handle
weapons you take it extremely seriously
but so I I don't know exactly how you
solve that problem I will just say it's
quite simple there's no discussion to be
had until the until the second amendment
is amended until the Constitution gets
an amendment you have no grounds to
argue for taking away anyone's right to
keep in bear arms
Erica Baum says for some reason I can't
watch your videos on your site it just
buffers starts over Etc I still pay to
support you but please make an app we'd
pay for it love y'all I'm sorry about
that we'll we'll I'll look into it could
it maybe be like your browser or
something maybe a different browser
connection maybe uh I think it's
probably not the connection if she can
watch videos elsewhere okay but uh also
we are working on that we are trying to
get the app done uh sap but my
understanding is that if you use the
brave browser you can listen to all the
videos on our site with your phone in
sleep mode the screen off because Brave
will allow the audio to keep playing
right I'm sure it's Brave that does that
right I think so yeah awesome we use
brave for everything Brave is my opinion
is the best browser absolutely
DW says hey Tim I'm from Lubbock Texas
where Chad was shot Kyle won't face
charges ex-wife is a county is the
County judge and he's currently got
millions in contracts with the city also
it wasn't it's a typo but I think this
wasn't his home he lived on the other
side of town so you guys know the story
about Chad Reed the video that came out
of the guy having an altercation about
his son and his wife was there it's a
crazy story so basically this dad goes
to pick up his son and he said he's like
where's my son it's 3 15 and the wife
said he's not here and he's like why
isn't here because I wanted to see him
so the dad's like I'm gonna haul you in
a court I'm gonna subpoena you and him
and them so he's angry but the threat he
made was a legal threat that's the
appropriate threat he's there as per our
court order to pick up his son but then
the ex-wife's boyfriend comes out with a
nine millimeter carbine and says get off
the property the dad Chad Reed gets in
his face and says you know I dare you
mother effer you know use it the dude
fires around in the ground they struggle
get knocked back then the the guy who
was there uh uh the father is on the
porch and the guy Kyle the ex-wife's
boyfriend gets thrown about 10 feet
raises the right raises the car mine and
just pop up and kills the dad like
almost on the spot he just hits the
ground so a lot of people are
questioning whether or not it would be
self-defense because the dude got in his
face but I was I was I did a segment on
it talking about an article from Andrew
branca plus my assessment and he said
it's probably manslaughter there's no
justifiable self-defense in this
capacity my attitude is like
if I'm court ordered to pick up my son
from my ex-wife
and then you come out with a gun and say
no you're kidnapping yeah you are here
by abetting a crime to kidnap a child in
violation of a court order yeah and all
the dad did was close the distance and
get in his face he did grab the gun but
the guy fires into the ground before he
grabbed the gun but either way my point
is and that's a good point though but my
point is if you are holding my son
against his will and against a court
order and then you bring out a gun you
are trying to kidnap my son with a
threat of deadly force so the dad trying
to grab the gun I would argue is in
defense of others they're kidnapping his
kid yeah yeah I mean it's a horrible
case it's a hard case to watch it not
have shot shot Chad reading yeah I mean
he wasn't I mean this Chad Reed was
making legal threats and only got in his
face when he pulled out a gun right yeah
so again if you're keeping my kid from
me and I don't have kids I can certainly
imagine I'd love to ask Jack about it
Jack would probably be like Jack Murphy
dude
you refuse to turn over my son to me
don't be surprised if someone at the
very minimum gets in your face of course
Chad Reed I I'm just saying this legally
probably not justified but I think on a
human level I'd imagine Chad Reed would
have been more than Justified to do a
lot to save his son from these people
taking him from him apparently he had
already called the cops so at this point
it's like he's threatened him with court
he called the police why did the dude
bring a gun out everything was going
well other than just yelling
now the dude's dead this is a messed up
story man messed up story I wish people
would have de-escalated on both sides
none your business says jizlane Maxwell
case uh we'll get into that in the
members only segment that's going to be
uh spices a lot of details a lot of
information has been without but we'll
definitely get into that stuff
all right let's see Jay says your
sponsor wraps you into a loop of other
purchases before you can finalize your
order I pulled my order but they still
have my card number oh man I'm sorry to
hear that uh I don't know we just uh got
the info on this thing on the stuff
today and I really thought the product
was pretty good but hit up the site for
sure yeah
all right Dragon Noodle Soup gaming says
hey Tim and Co I know you guys have
asked about when the last time new
Christmas songs were made the last I
remember was from The Polar Express 2010
I think
uh there's a lot of Christmas songs
these are like prominent ones you know
they never make any new ones Alan Shore
Tim bongino announced today on his show
he is recovering from breakthrough
covid-19 used the Rogers Rogan pool
cocktail
it's it's a doctor told me to take you
know they they gave they gave me an
inhaler too and I'm like I don't know I
didn't use it because I'm like I was
breathing but they were like this is for
emergencies we prescribe you a bunch of
stuff I don't know if I don't know if
that actually ever came up that we that
I got an inhaler like for emergencies if
you couldn't breathe but that was a part
of it I didn't have to use it I'm just
saying if my whatever the cocktail they
get is it's because a doctor was like
hey I think this is what you should get
okay doc I guess it's just this is
ridiculously moronic story where they're
like only listen to your doctor if he
prescribes fauci's method yeah like what
I don't know my doctor told me to do
something I said I guess or tells you to
go home and and you know walk it off
allegedly well here's my thing like when
the first doctor said walk it off I was
like they didn't tell me to do anything
they didn't give me an advice they
didn't explain anything to me they just
said sorry we have nothing for you so
that wasn't actually an opinion on
anything it was kind of the absence
thereof so that's why I was like okay I
guess I actually was going along with
that until I was like I'm gonna I'm
gonna talk to Joe about what he did and
what he was feeling because I wanted to
know like was Joe really sick was he was
bad because I was getting really bad and
Joe was like bro just call somebody yeah
and then I was like all right all right
so I was like I'll call someone else and
um and they were just like we want to
give you the full the full gamut of
these these treatments and this is a
this is a Maryland Baltimore uh doctor
this is not a Rogan's in Texas yeah that
that you know what I mean like so I was
just like okay Doc it's the the the cult
is so insane it's just absolutely
lunatics like listen to your doctor
unless he tells you to take what Rogan
took I guess no listen to your doctor if
your doctor gives you advice and you
don't like it you get a second opinion
and then you know that's what you do
John Curry says Luke is on fire tonight
yeah that opening bit was fantastic it's
funny people were saying you should make
a Garbage Pail Kids collection of all
the CNN hosts that sounds good too
oh it's right here actually yeah Dad
teaches and words to my son says Luke
just make the 2022 Garbage Pail Kids
lineup CNN Edition yeah might as well I
mean I'm writing that down I'm telling
my team right now
Garbage Pail Kids man
Matthew Wesley says Fredo will never be
fired yeah it's probably yeah
a squirrel guy says been watching since
the beginning keep up the great work
love the new site by the way hey
appreciate your membership
camel of the Mojave says Occupy Wall
Street was just a bunch of college kids
uh wanting a bailout on their own Macau
College uh I'm too I'm too stupid to say
no to learn a trade there were a lot of
people at Occupy Wall Street who are
very much like dur you know let me get a
bailout
but it was an Eclectic bunch in the
beginning the problem is I blame I blame
the right for uh for this to be
completely honest the leftists are
die-hard ideologues who are willing to
sleep on concrete or marble in the rain
to get what they want and the first week
I was there boy did I see a ton of
Libertarians conservatives Ron Paul
types in fact that's where I met Luke
but the right got up and walked away
after the first week and saying I'm not
sleeping on the floor at work today okay
yeah yeah a lot of people had work to be
fair but a lot of the right aren't
willing to go the lengths the left is I
mean let's be real the left is willing
to burn down buildings and infiltrate
media organizations to get what they
want it's horrifying the right doesn't
so nobody nobody cares there's no
there's no worry the right won't even
boycott things some people on the right
will be like I won't you know get a
Netflix subscription and then most will
be lying but the new show was out so I'm
just gonna buy it anyway and there you
go
you get what you ask for
ligamoth the guy on says
are any of us surprised by the Cuomo
allegations he has big time at Mel
Gibson in South Park energy
remember that
um no I don't but the Alec Baldwin
introduction into this story was also
not surprising because they all hang out
with each other it's just uh it's just
it's so crazy that all of them are just
buddy buddy friends together getting
away with shooting people and uh
stalking people and harassing people and
doing other unspeakable things to people
and uh just their own little special
Club
Aaron Stevenson says Kyle said Milwaukee
will burn if there was Foolery in the
Democratic primary
uh he says the violence helped mobilize
oh it says there was the violent top
mobilize it's not cool man get Jimmy
Dore not Kyle yeah
um I don't know yeah Jimmy would be
great yeah that'd be awesome Jimmy's
like very much a populist he's very left
you know Lefty but I also kind of feel
like they they both know they agree on a
lot of things and Jimmy has no problem
being like I know I agree in a lot of
things with Stephen because he's
Fearless the the leftists hate him
because he's honest yeah I disagree with
him on a lot of his economic opinions
right but he tells the truth and he
fired a guy over a misquote some guy on
his staff I guess took a quote and then
contracted it which kind of changed the
context and he fired the guy good and
the left was mad they're like oh how
dare he and it's like that was the right
thing to do like Jimmy was like he's out
but I think Kai would be good because I
think Kyle acts in good faith
um you know he does that show with
crystal ball Crystal might be great as
well yeah you know maybe Crystal and Ben
I think they'd have an interesting
conversation but you know I think Kyle
would be more interesting because uh
I think Kyle is well aware that he
probably does agree with a lot of these
people would be interesting to see that
Dynamic whereas Crystal and uh Sagar you
know they have a show together already
so of course she understands that the
right populist and left populists
overlap on a lot it's still crazy that
we were in the room when Jimmy Dore went
after Alex Jones
and me and Tim are just sitting there
like what in the world is happening now
how are we here that was the RNC right
yeah RNC or DNC in Cleveland I forgot
which one it was but we were inside the
Press media room who's the RNC I'm
pretty sure and then Alex just walked
right by us and then like took over the
young Target show and uh that was they
were doing their show like in the
hallway yeah like anyone could have
walked up and said Alex Jones did yeah
they had the Roomba cam going around as
well I remember that those were man
those are wild days
Cactus production says hello Tim and
crew from Oregon our state is trying to
implement a digital vaccine passport if
any oregonians are watching please email
members of the state legislature they're
trying to slide this right under our
noses
now I would be going back to uh Oregon
people I know in Illinois like my old
friends are just like it's bad
like everybody's on edge the more they
talk about the more the media fear
mongers the more they're worried it's
going to get locked down I'm hearing
from people that in some areas of
Illinois like Suburban areas their
businesses are like strict masks
restrictions all that stuff out here wow
I haven't really noticed anything
yeah I mean it all depends where you go
it all depends on the neighborhood it
all depends on how they're enforcing it
a lot of places even in places like New
York City they're not really enforcing a
lot of the mandates even a lot of the
Mask stuff in places like New York City
some people just don't care
Joel xling says if you guys think the
dog and monkey experiments are bad wait
until you read chapter 7 of rfk's new
book oh yeah the real Anthony fauci Dr
fauci Mr Hyde niaid's barbaric and
illegal experiments on children I think
we ended up getting that article yeah
yikes man it's been up for a while
that's crazy I love all the socks
someone mentions Pete Buddha judge
um but I love all the all the news about
you know like booty judges White House
run and rumors and I'm like that dude's
come on man I'll be honest though I
didn't think Biden could do it because
of his senility but uh uh Pete
butterjudge
if Biden could pull it off I guess if
Kamala could be in there anyway I'm
surprised myself I can't believe she was
able to still be in there
yeah she didn't win a single delegate
until she did better than she did no one
liked her
Mark Shaffer says my employer is
offering raises and the only eligible
employees of the vaccinated plan on
seeking legal advice that's interesting
because they can argue that it's not a
negative against you it's a positive for
someone else but then you can argue that
taking away the ability for a raise or a
potion from you is discrimination yeah
yeah oh okay what is this Nathan Simpson
says Rand Paul spent like 20 minutes
exposing government spending on stupid
research search senator Paul on spending
projects in science and technology bill
I think I remember that
December 17th it's awesome yeah right
yeah it's coming up so I'm going to be
paying attention to his Twitter account
for that Justin Casillas says never use
a 410 for turkey it is inappropriate uh
I mean maybe I don't know I haven't
actually hunted turkeys I just have a
410 and I bought a variety of 410 so
there's like slugs there's I got 410
buck and I got 410 game and 410 turkey
tomorrow we should get a hunting expert
on just to teach us how to hunt and make
our own food your own meat and have
someone on the show but then also do a
vlog segment where we learn how to do
this ethically and teach people how to
not uh rely on factory farms I think
that would be something that would be
worthwhile we're looking at making free
Namaste and totally self-sufficient so
we got a lot of work to do on the new
the new site we're probably going to
build a studio there we're probably
going to move a lot of the production
over there just because we're gonna have
we have more acreage and we can do a lot
more projects so we can actually have a
gun range and all that stuff a proper
range with you know all the safety stuff
and all the good stuff and so we want to
do solar power completely over the top
over producing the solar we would need
to operate the business out of this new
space and and to expand and then uh we
have you know survival people come out
and you know we'll grow our own food we
have a greenhouse already so we're gonna
be able to grow stuff all year round
it's gonna be fantastic build some
natural shelters that would be really
cool we'll get some shipping containers
we'll just bury them yeah yeah that'd be
cool yeah look a little I I guess I
think you know I don't really expect
ever to use a shipping container buried
as like a real bunker to survive
anything it would be a fun little like
little room to hang out in you know what
I mean put a TV down there some
recliners and just have a private little
secret underground thing and then you
know secret little tunnel when you open
it it looks like grass it's like a wood
thing with grass over so it's fun it'd
be fun man it'd be fun to have just
because it's silly not because it's
serious but yeah it's going to be cool
we're gonna be able to put on a really
great range
um I took a look at look at the property
again because we just finally like fully
secured it now we got to do a bunch of
utilities and power and and construction
and cosmetics but there's a great spot
the the wooded area actually look it
goes uphill nice perfect so it's
absolutely perfect we can easily set up
a good range probably up to a couple
hundred feet
we could probably do more Excavating and
even push that a little bit which I
think would be awesome if we if we tear
down the middle Hill area we could
probably do like 500 feet that'd be
awesome yeah massive crazy the issue is
though just you know Safety and Security
of everybody we gotta make sure it's
very very safe
Nevermore says the strange part about
the cult of fauci is wasn't there
candles for the guy working on the
Russia gate investigation too this isn't
the first time they were making Idols of
people yeah and Stacy Abrams there's
like uh uh I saw a picture of like a
little fouchy and it looked like a
Hanukkah thing
um what's it called Menorah a menorah
but it was vax it was shots oh gosh I
saw I saw a little nativity scene made
out of masks yeah I saw that on right
it's wrong with you people stop it's a
cult man it really is look I can I'll
say it again I understand that there are
some people that are like Q full Trump
they believe crazy things but you watch
like that Daily Show guy whatever his
name is no uh Trevor Noah no no no the
guy who goes on the ground and they give
him his own show but that got canceled
because it was dumb oh okay but he does
these things where he like shows up to
these rallies where there's much of
conspiracy theorists they're always old
people you know really a lot very very
much older who believe a lot of the more
crazy cult EQ stuff
we're sitting here on this show with you
know tons of viewers and we're like I
don't know about all that you know Trump
Q stuff I don't believe that but these
people have institutional power and
they're in a cult
and they get mad about it yeah whatever
I'm just glad that more and more people
are starting to wake up and realize it
uh miniaturized strange Quark says now
Tim is planning turkey town after
chicken City no no turkey town but we're
just about ready to start launching
chicken City so chicken city is up we
just need to now I think we ordered some
cameras we want to do waterproof PTZ
cameras it's pan tilt Zoom so that we
can have one camera move and look in
different directions so then we'll have
the chickens all do their thing I gotta
tell you man Roberto Jr he's so big it's
crazy so we we we had the original six
we got we got a a transplant and then
they had babies and now we have I think
uh what do we have seven babies and
they're all just so big it's crazy we
were gone for the week in Austin I came
back and I was like man those things got
huge
you'll get a bunch of roosters they're
awesome so we also we also inherited two
chickens at Freedom of stand so we're
gonna be moving a bunch of the roosters
over there to reduce the fighting so the
three black star chicken boys they're
friends and because they grew up
together we can keep them together
but
they should you know I was reading that
they should be fine technically growing
up and knowing who the boss is because
we have the one big rooster that's still
too many roosters so we're gonna take
away you know are they okay to move
Daniel Turner mentioned transplanting
chickens can be dangerous because you
take the toxins in their body to the
worms and stuff yeah but it's either
that or what we let them go yeah so we
can move them and it could be bad but
you know they're all adults so at this
point the the cockerels are getting very
close to adulthood but they're not fully
mature which the problem is if they
become mature then they could start
fighting with Roberto so we're gonna
have to relocate them to the other other
place but yeah uh Daniel was mentioning
you got to be careful about the
parasites and stuff that are in that
specific Coupe
but you know it is what it is
all right newbernine says the problem
with Unit 731 the Nazi experiments was
that they were conducted
unscientifically for instance they would
freeze limbs but not record the
temperature I would say the problem with
them is that they were human
experimentation cruel torturous and
psychotic but I get your point I get the
point I don't think he's it uh you know
diminishing The psychosis involved in
the horrific experiments but it is it is
a good point that that actually shows
just how depraved they were the fact
that they weren't actually recording
things show shows it wasn't really about
doing science it was the cruelty it was
just like I don't know let's see what
happens to to be fully Fair a lot of
what we know about some really bad
diseases come from really awful
experiments so that we need to find a
better way but right now what we have is
very much from these horrible
experiments unfortunately yeah I don't
know man uh scientific progress I mean I
think like you point out Justin a lot of
it is just waste yeah literally serving
no purpose not speeding up anything it's
just dumping money on ridiculous things
like do fish feel pain
I can't believe they actually did that
research and like yes they do it's like
okay the fisherman could tell you they
do you know what I mean the Festivus
report two years ago Rand Paul's report
included an example we had of uh yeah
nicotine addicted fish in England that
we're still paying for now oh wow yeah
well well you know it's got it got it's
got look if we're going to be selling
these you know these cool Marlboro 100s
or whatever fish we gotta know if they
get addicted because if they don't
what's the point
Fair Point yeah we have a salmon farm
can we get some cigarettes for them
they're all addicted I just don't
understand
you know I I suppose there's some
argument in seeing whether or not
nicotine affects Aquatic Life the same
way land mammals or something I mean
it's possible there's a lot of context
we don't get in some of these stories
but I really think it's incumbent upon
them to justify them when questioned you
know what I mean and if they can't maybe
we need to weed out the waste of money
but I think you make a good point
taxpayers should be fun to get
regardless it should be the private
sector yeah
all right Thomas sidebottom says I
watched Biden's announcement today
honestly for a second I thought it had
to had it had cut to a commercial
because it sounded more like a hard
sales pitch for the vaccines than
talking about covid-19 Omicron variant
oh yeah
Mr Zen Manser says Luke making Emperor
fauci I am the science shirt there you
go I like that idea I'm running my team
that right now uh like that chair when
he when it comes in I am the science
yeah no but it doesn't mean going around
like that already but it can't just be
that it's got to be like you know Mace
Windu or like someone saying or maybe
like you like you know we're here to
Quest criticize the scientific
establishment and then he says I am the
science or like electricity going
through his fingers and hitting an
orphanage
[Laughter]
let the science flow through you
custos
videos
says Tim for the love of God do not bury
shipping containers in the ground they
were designed to be stacked not buried
if you bury them too deep the weight
will destroy the container no I'm not
talking about like digging 10 feet in
the ground bearing and then dumping dirt
on top I'm talking about like leveling
it off with the ground so you can open
it and go right in like I'm pretty sure
that's fine well there's some companies
that are using it just you know they
don't bury it too deep they bury it
um just a little bit and it's still used
as uh like an underground little bunker
for some people you also um stack them
like like Jenga so you don't want them
all because they will collapse on
themselves but they won't collapse if
they're genuine do you see that hotel
that apartment complex they built of
shipping containers yeah and it got
postponed because of like you know
coveted stuff shortage of shipping
containers yeah that's what it was
Georgia yeah talk about the nightmare
dystopia our our low income shipping
container home or pods yeah our pods are
no longer available because they can't
get them yeah and the bugs aren't
available because they can't ship them
yep welcome man lee Nicholas says
legally it's not kidnapping the data is
supposed to go to the court and file a
motion as dumb as it sounds That's the
Law family court is broken I completely
agree
but um that's why I was saying the human
element here like you take a child from
his dad and then the dad gets angry
the worst thing he did was he got in the
face of the guy and started yelling at
him when he pulled out a gun on him I
wouldn't be surprised if he just
immediately tackled the guy to the
ground because he pulled a gun on him
yeah granted he wasn't brandishing it
but still crazy story man
yeah
erratic bear says is Omicron an autobot
or decepticon oh Alma crime would
clearly be a Decepticon definitely a lot
of people mentioning that Omicron is an
anagram for moronic
yeah I like that one
Scott Odom says Tim I designed uh Power
Systems and have done some solar hit me
up I'd be glad to help you guys figure
out what you need the challenge with
solar is just it just uh takes so long
we've been waiting I think seven months
or longer for Tesla to get the solar
done here so if you know somebody who
works at Tesla Tesla solar ask them like
we were approved everything's approved
we've been sitting here waiting for
months and they're just like we'll let
you know
maybe it's a shipping thing maybe they
can't get the the solar panels yeah but
we were gonna get like so um we had the
power go out here once during the summer
and we had to run the whole show off
these backup batteries that we have that
was exciting it was really hot like
we're all sweaty and it's dark but we
were able to do it yeah we did and then
I was like man what's going on with
those backup batteries we ordered from
Tesla man it's been forever months yeah
yeah yep
those power walls we get them this whole
place can operate for a couple days nice
that's exciting the power could go out
so the thing is being out in the middle
of nowhere the neighbor like the people
in the area have all said
if the power goes out it could be days
before they can figure out how to fix it
like if a line goes down you know it's a
rural area it's not a city so that would
be very very important but
it might come in handy during the
apocalypse yeah
definitely Joseph Hutchins says I live
in Danville Illinois about three hours
south of Chicago no one enforces masks
here every other city of decent size and
forces it but not uh enforce it a lot
more though that's basically what I hear
and I think it's it's it's kind of
similar in a lot of places like where
we're at we're about an hour from DC
DC's ridiculous people are freaking out
they're enforcing everything and then
you come out to West Virginia it's only
an hour drive and it's just like people
are shrugging there are a lot of
businesses though that do have signs up
saying like please wear a mask or
whatever but mostly people don't and I
gotta be honest I just don't go to them
so this is actually really funny uh
there was a mom and pop like Bakery and
coffee shop and the other day we went
there and there's a big sign saying
please wear your mask and I look inside
everyone's wearing their mask and then I
look behind me there's a Starbucks and
I'm like I walk over to Starbucks yep no
mask mandate yep and then I was just
like wow I really don't want to give
money to Starbucks but if the Mom and
Pop Shop doesn't want my business they
don't want my business I got no beef I'm
not going to go in there and argue and
be a you know Karen I was like okay I
didn't have a mask I got no problem
being like Oh I have a mask I can put it
on I didn't have one because most places
don't require it out here so when I
walked up and I saw it I was like I
don't got one all right let's go to
Starbucks I guess a lot of people have
those signs but a lot of them don't
enforce them from what I've noticed
myself personally some do some are very
strict about it and uptight but I don't
think arguing with your fellow man is or
woman is is something productive and I
think a lot of people get caught up in
the emotions of it and they're like
you're doing this and they make people
enemies when they're not supposed to be
enemies and you just you just got to let
your ego go and and stop arguing with
you know your neighbors for the most
part I don't think anybody enforces it
out here but my thing is like if I see a
big sign before you walk in saying you
know please wear your mask I'm gonna be
like okay I'm not going to go into their
private establishment and start causing
a problem for them I was at the airport
I missed my flight and spent about 17
hours on airplanes and Airport last week
and it's not surprising
yeah yeah get there early for the
holidays
in two hours is not enough I made my
flight I wore a mask for it was so wet
at the end of the day when I took it off
it was so gross it was wet uh I had to
keep pulling it out away from my face to
breathe dry air because it was so wet it
was so just clean your mask please wash
your mask tonight and think of me while
you do it
odd request but okay all right everybody
we are going to enter that members
segment and we're going to talk about
that Maxwell case we've been already if
you haven't already smash the like
button subscribe to the channel go to
timcast.com and become a member because
you get a massive library of all this
behind the scenes content we have two
new shows launching probably this week
get this we're doing some something
crazy
you really got to check out Tales from
the inverted World a lot of people you
know some people are saying I really
love it some people are like oh I don't
know if I'm into this show look look we
just launched it so it's getting into
its Groove it's getting going you got to
start something you got to build it up
but it's okay because eventually you
will come around the latest episode is
41 minutes long and it's about alien
abductions and YouTube put a big warning
on it being like alien abductions aren't
real and stuff but it's just talking
about a guy's story it's fascinating
there's music there's images it's really
cool
what we have on timcast.com is a members
only segment where we have Shane who
writes this stuff having conversations
with people about these stories and
these conspiracies like I don't think
conspiracy necessarily the right word
we're launching another show that is a
general conversation about all of these
random stories and random conspiracy
theories so there's the script there's
the written version say scripted but
like written in an investigatory version
where Shane Goes Down to Georgia and
investigates Ghost Stories and
abductions that is a members only
conversation but now we're going to be
launching a public conspiracy
conversation show and they'll both
promote the members only which is a
combination kind of of both so you're
going to want to check that out and that
will be that's going to be a free show
we're making thanks to you guys as
members we can make this happen and then
we're launching a pop culture show which
we'll also have more members content so
I'll tell you this
the more members content we produce the
more money we lose because we're not
making any extra money but we're hoping
it just makes more people want to be
members and funds more more work and we
can grow this business and create more
culture and do all that stuff so make
sure you're a member at timcast.com
because we're going to have a pretty
spicy segment coming up that being said
don't forget to smash the like button
you can follow us on Instagram timcast
IRL and basically everywhere else you
can follow me on Twitter Instagram or
whatever else at timcast Justin you want
to shout out white Coast Waste project
and any other sure yeah at white coat
waste on all social media platforms
whitecoatwaste.org and if you're feeling
like sending a note to your member of
Congress about Anthony fauci dogs
against fauci.org that's a great website
I like that website dogs against
fouchie.org yep and that's the one that
Twitter and Google have both censored
and won't allow us to run ads about
really wow well okay
um uh that's going to be a good website
I'm gonna be looking up myself uh and
personally I have my own YouTube channel
and media organization under we are
change so if you want to see my latest
rant and screams you can on youtube.com
forward slash we are change I did an
extensive video today about the Maxwell
trial it's definitely worth a listen and
uh because you guys do that I'm here so
thanks so much for checking out my
YouTube channel and uh Ian that's a very
nice exclusive t-shirt you like there
that you could get on the best
politicalshirts.com
thanks for uh getting me this shirt Luke
we are changed uh dot org is it uh it's
very warm yes hey thanks for coming
everyone glad to see you again my name
is Ian Crossland uh follow me Ian
crossland.net love you thanks for coming
bye I also have a Luke shirt that says
make 1984 fiction again which I love
wearing in public I feel like I get a
lot of side eye about it but no one's
really talked to me about it yet so I'm
still waiting I keep trying you guys may
follow me on Twitter at Sarah patch lids
Timothy I will yeah thank you we'll see
you all over in the members only segment
at teamcast.com thanks for hanging out
bye guys